Hamza Farooq: Oh…
Hamza Farooq: Awesome. Aishwarya, do you want to start with your side, and then we can… we can follow through?
Aishwarya Ashok: Absolutely.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, before… as we get started, any pending questions we can help answer?
Ashutosh Pandit: I just have a general structural question about skills and the agent itself. So, I understand skills can be used to, sort of.
Ashutosh Pandit: Call everything quickly and get out.
Ashutosh Pandit: sort of part of work done, right? But say, ultimately, when there is an agent, when we use the
Ashutosh Pandit: when we use an agent, right? And say, for example, my product, as I was saying, is, say, a vendor selection agent, for example, right?
Hamza Farooq: Yes.
Ashutosh Pandit: He says, help select a vendor for so-and-so task.
Ashutosh Pandit: Now, within that, do we need to keep using that skill, or does the agent start using the skill, and that's why we need skills? I'm trying to think, like, from an end-user experience, whoever's going to be using the agent in the form, for example, right? Do they need to know those skills, or is that skill mostly being developed so that the agent performs more effectively?
Hamza Farooq: So, think, and we'll discuss about this as we go through this session, but think of skill as a repeatable prompt.
Hamza Farooq: This part is clear, right?
Ashutosh Pandit: Yep, yep.
Hamza Farooq: Skill is a repeatable prompt.
Hamza Farooq: agent.
Hamza Farooq: Is an umbrella on top of the skill sometimes, so it can invoke multiple skills at the same time and use them.
Ashutosh Pandit: Got it, so that the agent doesn't…
Ashutosh Pandit: use a different prompt by itself every time, in a way, you're trying to put a skill so that it uses at least some guardrails in the form of that skill. Is that a way to think about it?
Hamza Farooq: A show you.
Aishwarya Ashok: knows exactly… it knows exactly what job to do, is how we put about it. So, let's say, to your question, there are times when a user is using the certain prompt, and then getting an action done with the skill. For an agent, there is an agent definition, right? There is… the agent is…
Aishwarya Ashok: destined to do a certain task or certain job. In order to get that job done, in order for the CTL that we keep speaking about.
Aishwarya Ashok: Skill is just a way to define certain actions for the agent. So, you can have one skill, you can have 10 skills as a part of the agent that you're building, it's just that when it touches the task.
Aishwarya Ashok: Having a skill is like a definitive layer for the agent to know, okay, given this task, I have a skill that gives me everything that I need to know to run this task.
Aishwarya Ashok: And then it can… it can be a combination. As we look at today, how skills and subversions are going to be, you'll get a clearer understanding of where to use skills and where subasions would be helpful. But it's a, like, a very TLDR answer to that is that a skill is a repeatable prompt, so it is a part of what lets the agent complete a task.
Ashutosh Pandit: And I think you guys will cover this, but I think what I'm trying to get out of the session also, maybe, in a way, is
Ashutosh Pandit: what is the best practice, or the most effective way to, sort of, where to skillify things, and where to not skillify them? Maybe let it do its own thing? What aspects are better done as a skill? What aspects are better left alone, for example? So, maybe… maybe that's sort of the larger question, right?
Hamza Farooq: this chart.
Aishwarya Ashok: Excuse me.
Hamza Farooq: This flowchart on the right, this chart will give you the idea.
Hamza Farooq: This is, this is how, how, how, how, how your things are.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, when I was trying to find the right, you know, synopsis of what we're gonna cover, this meme came the way. It's exactly what happens every Sunday.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, and the one good thing that we have done, like we've introduced in this class is
Hamza Farooq: hands-on building.
Hamza Farooq: So you guys will actually have the opportunity to follow along and build something yourself, which will go into the next class.
Hamza Farooq: So it will give you a very, very good idea on when to use what, and we have also a few things, added over here, that will sort of take you through that. Just a, you know,
Hamza Farooq: Like, if you, if you think about it, skill, again, repeatable prompt. Agent is an independent
Hamza Farooq: ecosystem that can still run a… that can still run a skill, but it has memory and other stronger things associated with it. So it's an independent freelancer, and you'll see how we will show you, you know, as we go through this session and the next one.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, and if you still have questions as we walk through the hands-on build as well, feel free… we'll keep discussing that, but yeah, we hope you get, like, a perspective by the end of the session, for sure.
Aishwarya Ashok: Cool, yeah, just to give you all an outlook of where we are, so we've been looking at the definitions of agents and the definition of skills, and today's class, we would touch upon the exact question we spoke about, which is where to use skill, what are sub-agents, and how exactly would sub-agents
Aishwarya Ashok: Help you with certain specific tasks in the same problem use case that you want to be building.
Aishwarya Ashok: And we'll also leave you with some clear differentiation between
Aishwarya Ashok: Can you still continue to use the skill, or is there a reason that you can convert the same thing to a sub-agent, so you completely understand what it means to use both in pallet, use both
Aishwarya Ashok: skills and sub-agents together as you build out your use case. So, all of the hands-on examples that we'd see today would cover the strong foundation for skills and introduce the concept of sub-agents, so that you would understand, how both work together.
Aishwarya Ashok: And as a part of helping you all build that foundation of skills, we wanted to take about 2 to 3 minutes to cover some of the questions that, you know, we keep getting across Slido, across a bunch of other students as well, and we thought it's a good recap to know how to use skills when it comes to building one. And most of you, we did go through the assignment that most of you submitted. It's great to see that
Aishwarya Ashok: you've all started to build some skills and understand where to put those skills. So as we look into that, I'll make a few recap elements so that you understand how skills work. We saw the root of all of this is the .clot folder, right? For every project, there's a .clot folder, and as we discussed last session about clot.md and scale.md, we saw that clot.md is
Aishwarya Ashok: It's always present at the root.
Aishwarya Ashok: And that's the first definition file that your agent automatically invokes.
Aishwarya Ashok: And any skill that you build with repeatable prompt automatically takes a house under the skills folder. So under .cloud, you have a skills folder, and all the skills that you build… in fact, if you go now, I'm sure all of you would have chatted with Cloud to build your own skill. But when you go back and look at the structure now, you would see that inside your .cloud folder, there is a skills folder, and that's where all of your skills are.
Aishwarya Ashok: So this is a general rubric to understand how the creation of a skill would be inside a .cloud folder.
Aishwarya Ashok: And the same thing for a sub-agent. So, today we'd be looking at sub-agents, and you would see that anytime you start building a sub-agent with Cloud Code, it automatically starts putting those sub-agents inside an agents folder that is present in your .cloud folder.
Aishwarya Ashok: So this is the fundamental structure that you start with to understand where things are placed for the specific use case that you're building.
Aishwarya Ashok: And what's interesting, I know this question came up, Ashosh asked this, a bunch of you all asked this last class, which is, can I use a skill across projects?
Aishwarya Ashok: can I use a skill that I built under one project into another project? And it is an absolute yes. So, there are skills and both Clot.md and skills. Both of these
Aishwarya Ashok: files can be present at two levels. One is at a user level, where you can use a skill across any project that you're building, so that the skill becomes
Aishwarya Ashok: If it's present within the user file of your .cloud folder, then it is going to be available across any project that you could start.
Aishwarya Ashok: And you can also have skills.
Aishwarya Ashok: at your individual or independent project level, which means only in that project, that particular skill can be used. So as you're building out a skill, you can get to decide how you want to call that skill, and based on that, the position of the skill, the position of that file would be either within your user's folder, or within the .cloud folder of your respective project.
Aishwarya Ashok: So that is one main key thing, and it's important that you also have multiple
Aishwarya Ashok: skills with multiple skills, you also ensure that there is no naming overlap, because when you have a skill in a certain name in your project, and the same skill with a different… or a certain name in your users, just ensure it's not clashing. So, anytime you create a skill, just ensure how you want to be using that, and then…
Aishwarya Ashok: You use that across, either of the projects or your specific project.
Aishwarya Ashok: And most of you would also be building it out as a part of your
Aishwarya Ashok: office project, or, like, your team project. So, it also works for a team project, which means as long as that Git repository is shared with your team members, that ClaudeMD, or that skill file, is going to be shared with anybody who's going to be using that project across your team.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, which means for any team project, the skill can be used by you and your team members, and all of you would all be able to see and use the same skill file.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, it's the same file, but it's a nuance that we want to help you understand that. You can use it under different circumstances. Yes, Hamza?
Hamza Farooq: And this is one of the questions that we keep hearing from a lot of our customers, is that we have in… we want to have…
Hamza Farooq: Standardized skills across the company.
Hamza Farooq: We want to have standardized skills across, a team.
Hamza Farooq: And we don't want people to change skill. I mean, they can change as often as they want, but we want them… we want them to have a starting pack, like a starter pack.
Hamza Farooq: And that is… that is what we hear more often, so…
Hamza Farooq: This is something that I think you all, would… it would be great for you all to start looking into it, that…
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, I mean, last week you got introduced to skills for the first time. Now you're getting introduced to, you know, you'll get introduced to sub-agents and skills at a deeper level, but how do you employ them across
Hamza Farooq: So that you work as a team.
Hamza Farooq: Rather than you working as individuals.
Hamza Farooq: So that's sort of, the way you put… where you place your plot folder, is a very important part on,
Hamza Farooq: Excuse me
Hamza Farooq: Where you place your skills itself is very important in how you define the usage of that skill across the board.
Hamza Farooq: Right.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yep.
Aishwarya Ashok: And you can continue, as we said, you can continue to hold certain skills as your personal skills, and certain skills as a part of your team projects, or your other sort of projects. So it is possible to have multiple skills concurrently. Everything that decides the usage is the position or the structure with which your skill find is present.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, as you keep building out more skills, it would be very easier when you build out just one skill or two skills, but as you keep building out skills for different projects and across different levels, just keep an eye and be very sure where you're putting these files so that you know where to access them.
Aishwarya Ashok: That's one very clear revision that we wanted to bring in as a part of building a skill.
Aishwarya Ashok: And we'll show this to you as we do a hands-on demo as well. So, in a nutshell, there is user, there's project, there's team project, and there's personal project. So, it's easier for you to create files across any of these levels.
Aishwarya Ashok: And the other thing that we want to discuss today is
Aishwarya Ashok: Building a skill is not just finding the prompt and making that task clearly defined, but it's also to understand how good the output of a skill is. So, which means you will understand
Aishwarya Ashok: whether the skill that you're building is good enough, and whether it is solid enough to give you the right output to the task that you want to be doing. So, we would also introduce you today, a bit early on, to the concept of evals, and we'll cover that, of course, in our in-depth session as well. But we want to give you a slice of… it's not just building a good agent system, but also being able to get good output from each of those
Aishwarya Ashok: So as we build a skill, and as we build a sub-agent, we would also look into what makes
Aishwarya Ashok: a skills output good, and what makes a subasions output good. So that way, you know, and you can look back with a right lens to go revise some of what you've built.
Aishwarya Ashok: both of these, both starvations and skills, only get better as you keep looking at the output and keep fine-tuning it until you arrive at a point that you know that this system is working well. So it's going to take you a couple of iterations, and that's absolutely fine, but you need to be able to look into the output and then have a very clear understanding that this is what I would want for the task.
Aishwarya Ashok: So that is also what we want to cover today.
Aishwarya Ashok: And as a recap, skill is what we looked into last week as
Aishwarya Ashok: a way to give a huge prompt into a certain task. So, a skill is a markdown file that lets you do repetitive tasks and have a definition for those repetitive tasks. So, which means, when there's a skill, you can simply call the skill with a slash command.
Aishwarya Ashok: And that slash command can be across project or across users. And you can create as many skills. I know I saw a couple of assignments where folks had about 3-4 skills as a part of the same project that they're building, and sometimes it's just one skill. It… everything depends on the
Aishwarya Ashok: Type of project and the type of the idea that you're building, but you can definitely have multiple skills, as long as you're giving it the right name and the right description.
Aishwarya Ashok: Because we saw that when you give a slush command, your agent would understand that it needs to call a skill only when it is able to match what you're asking with the description of the skill.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, once again, to repeat, that part is very, very important.
Aishwarya Ashok: How do you know the output of a skill
Aishwarya Ashok: Is literally what needs to give it, like, it's the right output.
Aishwarya Ashok: And this is where we say that the concept of evals would be very helpful, because what you're trying to do is write down what good looks like. So, every time you run a skill, every time you run the task.
Aishwarya Ashok: You have a… you have a definition of
Aishwarya Ashok: The skill's purpose is to do this job and give me a certain output.
Aishwarya Ashok: So as long as you're able to define and give that output, and give what that output looks like, then the process of evals become easier, because all you're doing is literally running tests to understand if that output is matching what your required output for that task should be.
Aishwarya Ashok: And in terms of skill, it's…
Aishwarya Ashok: pretty direct, because with skill, what you're literally trying to do is you're finding a repetitive pattern, and you know what exactly that pattern is going to provide as an output. So, defining the eval for a skill
Aishwarya Ashok: is pretty deterministic, because when you take a skill that says, convert this into a PRD,
Aishwarya Ashok: or when you take a skill that says, run this and give me a summary, or run this and give me a report, you kind of know how exactly the output of a skill should be. So, which also helps you define what we call as the golden output, which is you, as the user, would define what
Aishwarya Ashok: A good output looks like, and then against the output data that you build, you kind of run the skill to see if the output is matching the golden output that you'll create.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, every time
Aishwarya Ashok: a skill runs and gives you an output. What you're literally doing is comparing and then making that comparison to know how close the output of that skill is
Aishwarya Ashok: to the golden output that you've built. And that is how you would be able to improve the quality of the skill. So, the time that you run this is about 5 times, 10 times, and it's still not closer to the
Aishwarya Ashok: golden output that you're defining for the skill, then it gives you more room to go back and improve on the skill, because now you know what exactly the loopholes are. So what you're literally doing is using the agent as a judge to
Aishwarya Ashok: To look at the golden output, and to go repeat the same skill task over a number of times, and then
Aishwarya Ashok: As long as it comes very close to the output that you would need.
Aishwarya Ashok: Then, which means your skill has passed, and you have a proper sort of eval that is built over a skill, because it is deterministic, and you can exactly write the match that you would want to have. So, given an input.
Aishwarya Ashok: and given an output, what you're literally trying to do is match the input with the expected output that you have. And this is, like I said, easier because you know what exactly is that skill
Aishwarya Ashok: performing as a job, and it's easier to define the output of the job. So, defining the golden output becomes your first and foremost task, and then having those variations
Aishwarya Ashok: Running the same skill over and over, and to get the output and compare the output is the most fundamental part of building an eval for a skills.
Aishwarya Ashok: Any questions on this? I know EVALs is a new concept that we're introducing now, and this is the foundational concept, and we're going to go deeper into that as we go forward. But, any question here so far on what is a golden output, or just generally trying to understand building an eval?
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, I think Rupa had a question. In a team setting, is there a way to review the usage of skills across the teams and optimize its usage?
Aishwarya Ashok: Okay, optimize the usage in terms of adoption of a skill, or in terms of, like, the output, which is…
Rupa Bala: In terms of…
Rupa Bala: Yeah, like, in the example you gave, you're saying, hey, use this input and generate a document.
Rupa Bala: So, it could be a Word document, it could be a dashboard, it could be in any number of formats. Let's say, like, your basic skill is for a Word document, and you have Person A doing it for a spreadsheet, and Person B for, you know, a different look and feel.
Rupa Bala: My question is, is there a way for us to be intelligent about
Rupa Bala: Pulling it all in and saying, you know, this is… this is the definition of the skill, this is optimized to give various different outputs.
Rupa Bala: So that you don't have individuals within a team going off on a tangent and doing their own thing when someone's already done it.
Rupa Bala: You know, and they, they have it, available.
Rupa Bala: That's amazing.
Aishwarya Ashok: That's… Yeah, it does. And, so…
Aishwarya Ashok: That's one of the reasons why we said that having a skill at a team's folder level is definitely a start to ensure that everybody on your team uses the same skill. So, when everybody… we… last class, we did a Git clone, right? And all of us had a version of that project in our own local folders. So, having a skill at a team project level, even when everybody's able to clone and
Aishwarya Ashok: use a branch in their own local system. That skill is going to run and give the same output for every person who's going to be using as a part of that project.
Aishwarya Ashok: But to answer your question around, let's say someone's using it for one kind of a document, another person's using it for another kind of document, it also takes time for you to build a skill that works really well for the context of your team's problem, which is what we said as
Aishwarya Ashok: A part of running these input variations is exactly what you're saying, is each person being able to run it on a certain document, but to be able to condense those results and literally look, ultimately, for a skill
Aishwarya Ashok: when you can call a skill a skill is when you know the output is pretty deterministic. You know a skill is being used for a certain use case. Say, for example, if there is a summarizer, the output is in a certain format of a summary that you would want. It's not that your output is going to, you know.
Aishwarya Ashok: sort of contrastly vary across different elements, right? Even if the inputs
Aishwarya Ashok: are going to look in a file format, in an Excel format, in a dashboard format. The… a skill can only be useful for a task that you know the pattern of, or the task that you know is going to give you a certain output in a certain deterministic way.
Aishwarya Ashok: In that case, how can you improve the functioning of a skill is by introducing these different input variations, and then looking at the output, and then trying to analyze if the exact output that you want is right. If not, then you need to adjust the scale in such a way that it can take those multiple inputs.
Aishwarya Ashok: But you can't have a skill
Aishwarya Ashok: whose output you're still very unsure of, because you run a skill only when you sort of understand that the output is going to give you a certain task, or it's going to perform this task and give you a certain definitive formation of an output. So, I hope I was able to clarify, but…
Rupa Bala: Yeah, you are… so I guess my question was, the extension of that question is, like, can you ask Claude Code to say, hey, go across the team, look at how we are using it, and optimize it, and would it be able to do something like that?
Hamza Farooq: There's yes and no associated with that.
Hamza Farooq: Plot code does not work across teams.
Hamza Farooq: Unless you store something in a memory.
Hamza Farooq: And this is what a lot of focus on memory will be as we go forward.
Hamza Farooq: Each Cloud Code instance of yours is fixed.
Hamza Farooq: If that makes sense. I mean, or it's unique to you, it's not.
Hamza Farooq: like, whatever I'm doing, Aishwarya can only see whatever I have pushed for her to see.
Hamza Farooq: So what we can do is… so I just pasted a link called Skill Evaluator, it's from NVIDIA, and there's one more link I'll share with you guys in a minute. So, Aishwarya, if you want to open that link, and then another link?
Hamza Farooq: One… so there are two things which are happening.
Hamza Farooq: How do I know?
Hamza Farooq: How do I know that the skill that has been given to me is actually useful?
Hamza Farooq: Like, anybody can say, I'm gonna build you a skill that is gonna be the best skill in the world, and there's not a better… there's not a better skill.
Hamza Farooq: So, there is an entire framework which is created around that.
Hamza Farooq: This is from NVIDIA. I mean, we are showing you the simplest version of that, to be honest. We're showing you the simplest version of it, is that what we control. But there's an entire framework which is created.
Hamza Farooq: that you can run many robust experiments, and once you have run those robust experiments, you can evaluate and say, oh, through different tiers, Tier 1, Tier 2, Tier 3, that this is what the outcome of my skill would be, and we're going to show you more as we go through evaluations on how benchmarking has been done on skills.
Aishwarya Ashok: Hmm.
Hamza Farooq: You'll keep it consistent. But let's just say you work for a large company that needs their own internal things.
Hamza Farooq: The second problem that happens over there is that it is so unique to you that you can't build an evaluation until you only run on your own team.
Hamza Farooq: So you can use frameworks like these, or you can say.
Hamza Farooq: This is the skill that I need the deterministic output of this. This is how the deterministic output would look like. So you create a golden dataset, and then you basically
Hamza Farooq: go through it, like security, correctness, discoverability, effectiveness, and efficiency. So, this is the framework you can utilize, and we'll sort of break it down for you also, but this is a great starting point, for you to… for you to use that.
Hamza Farooq: So, right, Rupa, that's one part. The second part is, there are literally now hundreds and thousands of skills which are available online.
Hamza Farooq: So, Aishwarya, if you want to go to our favorite one, the… Yeah.
Aishwarya Ashok: We'll talk.
Hamza Farooq: People have, like, you know, people have…
Hamza Farooq: So, yeah, so people have, give or take, I think what Matt has is probably 100,000, at least 100,000, you know, GitHub skill. If you just put, yeah, skills, GitHub, yep. So,
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, it's… that link is just not showing up, but folks, give me a…
Hamza Farooq: So, he prob… this… this guy probably has, you know, probably 100,000, 100,000 stars.
Hamza Farooq: Which is a huge number to begin with.
Hamza Farooq: So, how do you know… how do you know that this skill, so, Aishwarya, I'm just sharing it on the link over here.
Hamza Farooq: Unless you're already on the page.
Aishwarya Ashok: not in.
Hamza Farooq: So, if you look at his number of stars.
Hamza Farooq: I think if you go to the skills, the skill, maybe the repo, it's here.
Hamza Farooq: He has 266,000 stars.
Hamza Farooq: Right? I mean, if you don't want to do your own skills, and you want to just copy someone who has done really well.
Hamza Farooq: This is one guy, but…
Hamza Farooq: The sad part is, maybe 20% of the time, his skills are useful in the environment we are working in.
Hamza Farooq: Right? So, you have… you can pick up his best skills, you know, like, you can… so if you go to click on skills, we can see, some of the skills.
Hamza Farooq: And why do you think he's updating them every single day? Like, he updates them, he deprecates them, because he's continuously testing and getting feedback on his skills from other people.
Hamza Farooq: He's looking into them. Grill Me, Grilling, handoff. Handoff is a…
Aishwarya Ashok: Grillby became so pop… I think the Grillby and the handoff were so popular among a lot of his kids.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, and what Anthropic did is that they also copied a bunch of them.
Hamza Farooq: So, but then, what if you go… you find a skill, it seems too good to be true, and you're like, I need to know whether it works or not? So, on the fourth link on your tab, scan agents before,
Hamza Farooq: This is another interesting skill, or another platform where you can actually look for prompt injection
Hamza Farooq: data exploration, privilege escalation, supply chain issues, excessive agency. So, there are a lot of things that people can insert into their skills.
Hamza Farooq: And you basically use those skills, like, people can try to put prompts, so you can also evaluate your skills against, you know, this is a platform again, that will help you test
Hamza Farooq: If your skill is valid and you should use it or not.
Hamza Farooq: Right? So, long answer to your short questions, but these are two things that have come up recently, so we have started to incorporate that in our learning skill evaluator, which is a robust framework to know how well your skill works.
Hamza Farooq: Remember, we have an agent framework also, so you'll have to use… there's an agent framework also, which we'll talk about, and then there's a skill, evaluate… a skill tester to… to test for, you know, whether there are any kind of issues or things that we might be seeing over here.
Hamza Farooq: Alright?
Aishwarya Ashok: a version of this is also what you can build within your team projects, because when… when people say that teams have adopted skills internally, it's not that there's one person who builds it, and then overnight everybody sort of takes in and then adapts to it, but then it is being able to collectively get the outputs across. So, in this case, you can have that one skill that was being built.
Aishwarya Ashok: But it can also have what that golden output should look like. And as everybody on the team keeps using that skill and building the skill, that output can be saved onto a memory file within the same project. And using that and using your golden data, you can arrive at how to improvise that skill file, so that once and for all, you know that this is what runs it. Now that can be completely adopted across
Aishwarya Ashok: you know, the entire company. A lot of companies, like Slack, Salesforce, a lot of them have internal skills that they've built this way, which is…
Aishwarya Ashok: The entire marketing team, or the entire product team, or the entire sales team would be trying and testing upon what the outputs across different people would be, and then fine-tuning the skill to be able to go put that out into a sort of a deployment, and everybody can use.
Hamza Farooq: Huh, so Sudhamshu, you made a point, do you want to share it here?
Sudhamshu Mitra: Yeah, I mean, I just want to give what's happening in my company, in the sense that
Sudhamshu Mitra: I mean, there is a skills repository, and, people can upload their skills, and…
Sudhamshu Mitra: other team members can use it. But the issue is that I found it
Sudhamshu Mitra: better as a project manager to let people build their own things on their cursor, but if it's for a team-wide usage, I'm trying to build some sort of a portal for our own team, and then there is a centralized repository and skills out.
Sudhamshu Mitra: Agents that people can use, and which has a
Sudhamshu Mitra: Consistent output that's required for the DNA.
Sudhamshu Mitra: across.
Hamza Farooq: Yep, yep. You know, what we are also seeing is it's good to teach what skill is to people, because most people are like, I don't know what skill is, and there's a bit of a confusion between what a skill is, what an agent is, and…
Hamza Farooq: To be honest, It's… it's not really a big differentiation between them.
Hamza Farooq: But people are like, I don't know when should I use a skill, when should I use an agent, and how do I build a skill? Is this a skill? Is this a good skill?
Hamza Farooq: And how often should we use that? Because sometimes we just say, okay, you know what, we're gonna skip all our… all our skills, and we're just gonna stick to our own prompting, because prompting is the easiest way to work with.
Hamza Farooq: And you guys will see, like, hopefully during the session, you will see that
Hamza Farooq: when you just use prompting and basic skills, like, you just keep prompting your system. When I say prompting, is that you write what you want in the beginning, and then you let it go?
Hamza Farooq: It… you will see that it creates a lot more work for you, whereas if you can build… the word we use, harness, if you build something like an infrastructure, which is already built out, you can get… it's called the reusable part.
Hamza Farooq: Which… which we'll… we'll discuss as we go through this session and, you know, what we have in store for you. One more thing shobhit said, good or bad… good or bad, a skill depends on golden data set, which can vary from use case.
Hamza Farooq: Shobhit, I think I'll take it further for you. Sometimes you don't even know what your golden set should look like.
Hamza Farooq: So the reason this is an iterative process is because we don't know what good looks like.
Hamza Farooq: Good is something, in a lot of cases, we have… you only know what is good if you have historical data on that.
Hamza Farooq: If you do not have a historical data on it, you don't know what good is. So you basically set, like, a standard
Hamza Farooq: And LLM, or, you know, Claude can also help you with that, like, come up with a standard and say, this is the standard that you should follow.
Hamza Farooq: And once that standard has been achieved, then you can move ahead and, you know, sort of build things from there.
Hamza Farooq: Shobit…
Aishwarya Ashok: Especially…
Hamza Farooq: But…
Aishwarya Ashok: Sorry, I was gonna say, especially when we look into the demarcation of skill versus abhin, with skill, we at least see that there is task completion, so there's some amount of golden data, or some amount of
Aishwarya Ashok: qualifiable output that we know is there. But as we build salvations, rightly, as Hamza was pointing out.
Aishwarya Ashok: we can only take a cut at a very standardized way of saying, okay, this is what could look like, because we do not arrive at a very deterministic output to say, this is exactly what you need to follow. So in those cases, we would look into defining what we call as rubrics, and as we get to subasions, we would understand a little bit more about how to define those rubrics. The idea is we're constantly oscillating between
Aishwarya Ashok: Okay, we know for this use case what exactly output looks like, across to the other side, which is, we're gonna let
Aishwarya Ashok: the memory, and we're going to let the iterations show us what that good would look like, and that is why PMs across different teams are spending a lot of time on evals. Like, they're spending a lot of energy and effort into defining evals for every project that they're doing.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah.
shobhit gupta: So, just on… on this golden dataset, so…
shobhit gupta: Evaluating a scale, let's say… so, do we have a golden dataset separately for a scale evaluation versus agent evaluation, or we'll have only, let's say, a use case where we have a common golden dataset? We evaluate the scale based on that, we evaluate the agent based on that.
shobhit gupta: So, how does it.
Hamza Farooq: That's a good, good question.
Hamza Farooq: A skill, as we all know, is a repeatable outcome, right? It's a deterministic output. We can have a golden data set for that.
Hamza Farooq: But when you have an agent, an agent… you don't test the agent on the…
Hamza Farooq: expected out… like, you do test it on the expected outcome, but you don't have a golden data set. Like, for example, if I go to Lovable, and I say, build me a website, that's an agent.
Hamza Farooq: There is no way possible for me to know the, you know, how to test that outcome.
Hamza Farooq: So, sub-agents are non-deterministic, which basically means is that
Hamza Farooq: The out… the work that you need out of them is so big and so massive.
Hamza Farooq: That it will not come out to you… it will… every output will be different.
Hamza Farooq: So, within the ability to test agents, what we do is that we actually say.
Hamza Farooq: Did you follow the process? Did you follow all the requirements that I gave you?
Hamza Farooq: to build something. So, there is a different rubric, which we'll get to, of how you determine how your sub-agents work, rather than for skill, which is simple, like, this is the output, this is the input, this is the expected output, the input, output, input, output.
Hamza Farooq: Agent is a multi-tier system, which requires… did you follow step one? Did you follow step two? Did you follow step 3? So it's like cooking.
Hamza Farooq: Did you follow all the steps? And if you miss one step, you will get it wrong. You put too much salt.
Hamza Farooq: Think of skill as putting salt. Put one teaspoon of salt.
Hamza Farooq: Whereas, the agent is a full biryani dish.
shobhit gupta: So, so I was thinking, Agent from that React discussion which we had, Hamza, so, like, there is a goal, and until that goal is achieved, it will iteratively loop. So, yeah, I think you say that loop… that loop involves the process, not just the…
shobhit gupta: Let's say final, yeah, okay, thanks.
Aishwarya Ashok: In fact, the skill is a part of that loop, so imagine that what you're doing, ultimately, to define what good looks like for the agent is define what good looks like at every level. In certain cases, such as a skill, defining that gets slightly deterministic, because you know that when a skill runs to perform a certain task, you know what that output looks like. Versus, as a part of the same loop, the React loop, there could be another subversion that runs, or there could be another part of
Aishwarya Ashok: the process where defining those, specifics would become harder.
Aishwarya Ashok: What we would do there is to look at and say, did you follow the step in a certain way? Did you skip anything?
Aishwarya Ashok: did you give me an output that… in a format that I would not want? So, what happens is, instead of saying, this is exactly what you need to give me, the definition of
Aishwarya Ashok: golden data set there would be built around certain checklist or questioning around, like, what we call as rubrics, which is mostly for the cases where definitive output is so hard, and what you tend to do is conditional check, or knowing that whether certain conditions have passed, whether certain things have been identified, and if not, why have they not been? And that gives you
Aishwarya Ashok: the complete evals together. So think of it as wherever skills are employed, you use determinism. Wherever agents or, you know, where we know the output is not definable, then certain sets of clarifications or rubrics come into picture. And together, they all make up the agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: So your agent will have multiple levels of evals inside it.
shobhit gupta: Thanks, yep.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, and getting back, Hamza, do we want to do, like, the hands-on part of the skill and then enter into subasions, so that it would be easier for people to follow through the, the skill path?
Hamza Farooq: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: One more thing is, do…
Hamza Farooq: Verda, can you share the link that you built? And, Aishwarya, if you can take us through that also. I mean, I know you're opening up.
Hamza Farooq: So, guys, what we did is that we…
Hamza Farooq: You know, it's always interesting to do hands-on, but what is the best way to do hands-on? So we came up with a new method.
Hamza Farooq: And we wanted to get your feedback on it. This is the first time we are… I mean, we've tried this before.
Hamza Farooq: But what we did is that, verda came up with the idea that why don't we build a step-by-step process?
Hamza Farooq: So, it's almost like a self-paced course for you guys.
Hamza Farooq: So, let's just say I'm repeating something in the… I'm saying something in the class, I'm giving you instructions, and you're like.
Hamza Farooq: Oh, I forgot what 3 and 4 was.
Hamza Farooq: And then we skip it, right? This is literally every single step.
Hamza Farooq: That you can follow.
Hamza Farooq: to, you know, like… and you can keep it, like, this is basically, you don't have to follow through every single thing in the class, you can do it at your own pace also. So…
Hamza Farooq: So you basically say, you know, do we have Clot installed and signed in? So let's say we do a check on that. Do we have VS Code installed? So we do a check on that. So, if you want to add a check to that. And then it basically, you know, then says.
Hamza Farooq: open a folder, start Cloud Code, let's name this folder, you know, debrief.
Hamza Farooq: And it's sort of just… it's a starting point for you all.
Hamza Farooq: And here we have used terminal, you could use the chat over here also, I think… yeah, this is… this is the chat, sorry. You can, you can use the terminal, you can use the chat, whichever way, way you want.
Hamza Farooq: But you can basically use any one of them. If you can also, add the chat… the chat option also, so people can follow through the chat.
Hamza Farooq: But hey, and then you basically, it will follow through all the steps.
Hamza Farooq: Every single step that will help you build a skill, that will help you build a sub-agent.
Hamza Farooq: Then, an agent team, and then have a memory and all the capability around that.
Hamza Farooq: So this is, to us, you know, one of the ways that we felt like would be a great way for you all to follow through and build something hands-on with us at the same time.
Hamza Farooq: And… Sorry, I keep coughing.
Hamza Farooq: And then… and then build with us as we go through.
Aishwarya Ashok: And some of us had questions, especially in the last two weeks, on how to create certain types of files, how to get started, how… where do you go and clone a repo, how would you set up skill, what would that structure look like, can I have multiple skills? So.
Aishwarya Ashok: our way of giving this guided sort of a setup is to help you that anytime you want to come back and look into the steps, it's always going to be there, so that you can, for any project that you come up, you can always look at this as a visual guidance on how to go about from one process to another. So…
Aishwarya Ashok: I think the link is on the chat, perhaps, and all of you would be able to access this, and all of you can have, like, a check that you do at your own site.
Hamza Farooq: But we will be taking you through some of it in the class, today, so that you can sort of get your hands on to building it. So, first question, does everybody has this open? Do you all have this on the side available to you?
Hamza Farooq: Right? Second thing is that just make sure that you bookmark it. We'll give you a better Versal link, this is directly on Vercel right now.
Hamza Farooq: we'll add, you know, we'll add something behind it. Verda if you can reshare the link again with the team?
Hamza Farooq: Actually, I will. So, this is… this is the link. Alright,
Hamza Farooq: Sorry, Algar. Alright, so let's take them through this.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, so as soon as you create a folder and you have the step of opening VS Code and creating a folder, just ensure that you start with your Cloud Code terminal, so open your Cloud Code terminal.
Aishwarya Ashok: And what we've also done is given you an example of what kind of folders you can create within the Cloud Code terminal, and a sample of
Aishwarya Ashok: what you can add for this particular use case to work. So what we're doing here is a debrief sort of an agent, and that agent is going to have a couple of skills and a couple of sub-agents that we've been looking at today. And the whole concept of debrief, is to take a transcript, such as our own class transcript, and to give you an output in a certain format. And that could be as a report, that could be as an
Aishwarya Ashok: email, so we have skills that, give you the output in a certain format, like an email. And we also have sub-agents that help you run the same transcript and give you an output that gives you, like, a list of FAQs and list of, like, takeaways from that particular module.
Aishwarya Ashok: And this, both from Verda's context, it helps a facilitator, yes, but from a student's concept, it also helps you all to go through what you've learned in the previous class, and then align at the output that you would want.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, we've given you… sorry.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, does anybody want to volunteer and go through this with us?
Hamza Farooq: This will be easier. So, anyone who wants to… I know we had a couple of people last time who wanted to take us through this, Andreo, Andrei, Jonlin, anyone… I think, Andrew, was it you last time who… who was with us? I'm trying to remember who it was.
Hamza Farooq: But anyone who wants to go through, like, step by step, as we are building it, and you guys build it with us, like, so, instead of us showing you, one of you share your screen, and we will… you will follow along. Like, we… the whole class will follow along with you.
Hamza Farooq: If not, then we'll, we'll pick up someone, or I can, I can take over and sort of show you guys, as we go.
Andrei: I can, I can try, I can try Hamza.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, Andrei, let's go. So, let's start, let's have you share your screen.
Hamza Farooq: let's open your VS Code, and then if you want to open this… this,
Andrei: The only thing is that the share screening is disabled. How do I…
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, I can… I can enable. So if you send a request for it.
Hamza Farooq: I'm trying to figure out why I can't enable it myself now, but if you request to share, send a request, I will be able to…
Andrei: Okay, how do I do that?
Hamza Farooq: Okay, now you can.
Andrei: Okay.
Andrei: Yes.
Andrei: One second, Chrome.
Andrei: And some permissions as well.
Andrei: I will have to reopen Chrome. Sorry, I have to reconnect.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, that's right.
Chandreyee: I had a quick question before I may ask.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah. Yes, please.
Chandreyee: I think, I wanted to ask, right, this setup is very helpful, thank you for that, but if you're thinking, if we are thinking of an idea, right, usually, like, I would,
Chandreyee: You know, think about that idea, research about it, create a PRD.
Chandreyee: And then, I start working on the project, right? Like in Cloud Code, and follow these steps, right? So the…
Chandreyee: what I… I went through the first module, and it seems like it says, like, you go and create the cloud code, write it, right? Usually, would you do that, or because you have the PR, do you know what you want to do around it,
Chandreyee: I mean, are you guys writing yourself, or are you, like, creating a plot code based on your idea, outside, and then, you know, just copy-pasting it there?
Hamza Farooq: We usually write a PRD, the PRD gets saved, and then we create a .md file from there.
Chandreyee: Okay, so you are inputting your PRD, and then possibly asking Claude to generate the Claude code based off it, and then you're going and verifying it, right? Is that right?
Hamza Farooq: Yes, so that's… that's what we have in our cloud. So if you go see the… if you go to the Cloud Code startup, there's a PRD, there's a IDS.
Chandreyee: I know.
Hamza Farooq: In that, you will see You will, you can see…
Hamza Farooq: actually, that save this to my folder, and then you can say, my folder is here, my PRD is here, can you make me a claw.md file and get started?
Chandreyee: Correct.
Hamza Farooq: Right?
Chandreyee: And another thing, I mean, for me, while I was doing this assignment, basically, it got very complex for me, because when I was doing this PRD, I spent a lot of time in the PRD, and also brainstormed what are the skills, etc, that I can use, and agents that I can use as part of this, you know, the entire build.
Chandreyee: So when I started, I started off with all the instructions, like, okay, go and create the skills, and…
Chandreyee: kind of got lost in between. It was so many things, and then, for example, when I'm building one module at a time, I've given it instructions about, like, the skills that it needs to use, and also some instructions about the agents, like the software build agents, the testing, verifying agents, and it became so complex that I kind of
Chandreyee: Lost my way in between, trying to figure it out with the help of this
Chandreyee: Would you give some, basic guidance around it? Like, what is the best way to go ahead, build it, and then
Chandreyee: Kind of build on top of it.
Chandreyee: If it makes sense, I don't know.
Chandreyee: Hamza, you're on mute, sorry.
Aishwarya Ashok: You're on mute.
Hamza Farooq: happens to at least one of us. Let's come to it, Chandrey, on this. I want to make sure that we get started with skills.
Chandreyee: Sure, sure, okay.
Hamza Farooq: We might be able to ask some of it as we go.
Andrei: And you see my screen now?
Hamza Farooq: Yes, we can.
Andrei: Okay, cool. So then I'm going to follow these steps here.
Hamza Farooq: Make a folder, yeah.
Andrei: Yes, I don't know how much you can see, if it's too…
Hamza Farooq: Yeah.
Andrei: Okay, does it matter where? Not really, or…
Hamza Farooq: You wanna start a new folder? Yep.
Hamza Farooq: And then… You've got a debrief, yep.
Hamza Farooq: And then you create it, and then you're good to go. Open.
Hamza Farooq: Alright. And then you can close the chart on the right.
Hamza Farooq: And then you open Cloud Code here.
Andrei: Okay.
Andrei: What was the trick?
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, I think it'.
Andrei: on the sidebar.
Aishwarya Ashok: You just go click Manage.
Hamza Farooq: This is…
Aishwarya Ashok: Restricted mode, yeah.
Aishwarya Ashok: Trust.
Hamza Farooq: Now you'll see Claudia.
Hamza Farooq: And then you open a new session.
Hamza Farooq: Right? And then you can drag the clot code on the left, so it will become one overall screen. So, if you go to the top, scroll at the top. No, no, at the top, yeah.
Hamza Farooq: No, on the right side?
Andrei: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: And then you drag this very thing to the left. No, no, just drag the clot code itself.
Hamza Farooq: Yes, like this.
Andrei: Okay.
Hamza Farooq: Right? So now you have everything over here. Now you click on File again on the left top, top left.
Hamza Farooq: So you have a folder… no, no, no, here.
Aishwarya Ashok: a folder I could…
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, the full VS Code, yep, right? So you have everything here, and then you click on Cloud Code. Alright, what's the next steps?
Hamza Farooq: So, you basically…
Hamza Farooq: You can use the terminal also over there. But you could… so let's just try and not use terminal. Now, why don't you copy the next part?
Hamza Farooq: So this is done, so let's say you.
Aishwarya Ashok: now.
Hamza Farooq: I'm gonna check on it.
Andrei: Okay.
Hamza Farooq: You put a check on it, you say, you're done, alright? So let's go to the next one. It says, okay, so you can copy the clot prompt.
Hamza Farooq: You can hit copy, and it will copy, and then you can paste it here.
Hamza Farooq: So there you go. It built your folder. It built you the folders, right?
Hamza Farooq: then you want to go… and it will show, it'll tell you, I have a transcript folder, I have an output folder, you know, you have all those things available to you.
Hamza Farooq: Alright? Then what you want to do is that you want to scroll down, so that you can put a check on that, right?
Hamza Farooq: Then you scroll down and say, okay, download the module. So you want to click on download the module.
Hamza Farooq: You downloaded?
Hamza Farooq: And once you've downloaded it, you can save it in the transcript. So if you… if you want to go to where your code is.
Hamza Farooq: Debrief and transcript.
Aishwarya Ashok: Transcript. Transcript selections.
Hamza Farooq: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: Perfect.
Hamza Farooq: So now you just saved it over there. You're working, you're going faster. Alright, and then we put a.
Andrei: Sure.
Hamza Farooq: Right? Then what we do is that write CloudMD and the file
Hamza Farooq: So now you have something in your transcript.
Hamza Farooq: Now what you want to do is you want to copy the clot.md.
Aishwarya Ashok: I've given you the cloud.nd construct here, but the idea is, in another project, you would be able to just start with Cloud Code and get it. To help you here, we've given you the exact thing to copy-paste.
Hamza Farooq: So you can…
Andrei: So I just placed this one.
Hamza Farooq: So you can, like, create my cloud.md file here, with this.
Hamza Farooq: create my clod.md file, with the following.
Hamza Farooq: Got it.
Andrei: Like this.
Hamza Farooq: Nope.
Hamza Farooq: And now you see, you see .clot got added.
Hamza Farooq: the .clot folder it got added, and then you have the clot.md.
Hamza Farooq: Right, so if you see on the left, you will see it's following the same process.
Hamza Farooq: Right? And so you can hit check on that.
Hamza Farooq: I think we should move the check to the bottom.
Hamza Farooq: Oh, done.
Andrei: That would be more intuitive.
Andrei: That works.
Hamza Farooq: And then now you write, you copy this, and then ask this question.
Hamza Farooq: So, you see, what you just did is that you build
Hamza Farooq: the project setup for you, right there. This is your project setup. Like, now, if you ever open your Cloud MD, and then you're like, hey, what do I do over here? What is going on? Or you ask your session, you'll be like, oh, this is all the things you need to know.
Hamza Farooq: So, this is basically how we run things behind the scenes, is basically, following a pattern and saying, okay, now your co- your project is set up.
Hamza Farooq: This is one way of doing it, so you don't have to, like… this is sort of just helping you get started and having everything in a single place.
Hamza Farooq: Right? Any questions from anyone at this point, like, what we have done?
Hamza Farooq: Or, if you've not been able to get there. So, Andrei, if you want to check on the left, step 5, so you're good to go.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, so we have done all these steps. Okay, let's click on next.
Hamza Farooq: At the bottom.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, so now you will build your first skill.
Hamza Farooq: Alright? So, remember, skill is just a… just one prompt, one repeatable prompt, that you use.
Hamza Farooq: So, there are a few skills that you can copy from the repo, but we'll be sort of going through them ourselves, so we'll basically go through that. So, if you scroll down…
Hamza Farooq: So, this is your step one.
Hamza Farooq: In your skill folder, so you could either follow this step.
Hamza Farooq: Or, what you can do is you can just copy this.
Hamza Farooq: The text at the… yeah, just copy and say.
Hamza Farooq: Create me a skill called recap-email.
Hamza Farooq: And it should, yeah, skill, named recap dash email.
Andrei: recap.
Hamza Farooq: Yep, email, that does the following.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, if you notice in… as he's creating, the structure of this skill file.
Aishwarya Ashok: actually has the name, and the description, and also the slash command. It says slash, recap hyphen email, and what it is supposed to give as the output format. So the task in this case is create a recap email.
Aishwarya Ashok: And just tying it back to the discussion we had, creating an output dataset as deterministic as this is simpler, because you now know a recap email's job is to give you an output in a certain format.
Aishwarya Ashok: So creating a golden data set for something like this is, very deterministic and something that you can have the skills run multiple times and come closer to the actual output that you would want.
Aishwarya Ashok: Okay, so… Screw to the skin.
Andrei: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: So…
Hamza Farooq: Can you see, can you do forward slash, so let's go to your .clot folder and see if it's there.
Andrei: I'll like that.
Hamza Farooq: There's a folder called .clawed, yep.
Hamza Farooq: Just below debrief, there's a folder called Claude.
Andrei: Oh, no.
Hamza Farooq: It's usually called dot clot.
Hamza Farooq: But if you, yeah, if you click on skill.md and do right-click and do preview, Open preview.
Hamza Farooq: You see, all of that is here.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, now let's go to your Claude.
Hamza Farooq: You don't want a new session, and you can continue with the current session.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, and then do forward slash and see if it shows up.
Hamza Farooq: In some VS Code, it is able to show up early, and some… so do forward slash.
Hamza Farooq: No, I guess.
Andrei: Is that for this?
Aishwarya Ashok: The question that… yeah, this is all such.
Hamza Farooq: So, if you want to do recap, if you write recap.
Hamza Farooq: Re… this is, this is the different one.
Aishwarya Ashok: No, I think sometimes it requires you to open up, like, there's either, like, a refresh of skills, if not, it requires you to open up a new session.
Hamza Farooq: So let's come to the second one, which you had opened already.
Andrei: this, one?
Hamza Farooq: Yes, this one. And then do forward slash?
Hamza Farooq: Right? Recap dash…
Andrei: There it is.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah… Recap-email.
Hamza Farooq: Interesting. Good.
Aishwarya Ashok: you…
Hamza Farooq: Yeah.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, I was just gonna say, do you wanna, like, restart, VS Code, perhaps? Because sometimes that happens, like, either the extension itself, like, sort of, like, refresh cloud code, or restart,
Hamza Farooq: If you want to close this and open this again?
Hamza Farooq: Sometimes, sometimes it happens.
Andrei: Let's try.
Hamza Farooq: And then you can open the same folder.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, let's try, let's try this now. Do forward slash.
Hamza Farooq: Yep.
Andrei: Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: You see? And then…
Hamza Farooq: So this is basically, now what you want to do is, if you go to transcripts, let's, let's show you the transcript.
Hamza Farooq: Actually, it picked up itself.
Hamza Farooq: So you… so let's read what the recap is.
Hamza Farooq: So if you go to the skill.md.
Hamza Farooq: And do right-click and do preview.
Hamza Farooq: With the previous order.
Andrei: It's already open, huh?
Hamza Farooq: So, what recap email is, is basically
Hamza Farooq: You basically… it's just saying that you need to read, you need to read my transcript.
Hamza Farooq: once you have read the transcript, wherever I've given you, this is where you will… you can find the transcript.
Hamza Farooq: Take the topics from what instructor taught using definition in cloud.md, collect every announcement the instructor actually made, never invent a deadline, and you see… so what you did is that this is the recap email format that we want to send to our students.
Hamza Farooq: So this is a skip.
Hamza Farooq: Now, I don't have a golden dataset for this, so if you guys think about it, I don't have a golden dataset. I don't know what it should look like.
Hamza Farooq: But I have given a area of what the idea should be on how we do it. If you scroll to the bottom.
Hamza Farooq: Basically, these are the rules we have told it to follow.
Hamza Farooq: So, shobhit, when you said, you know, like, the React part, this is also the React part, where it will look at the skill, and it follows the rules that I've given.
shobhit gupta: Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: It will follow the rules that I've given.
Hamza Farooq: So now, if you go to the clot code part.
Hamza Farooq: Not here, not here, it's already open. So if you go to the right part… no, no. At the top right, the recap, yes, this one.
Hamza Farooq: Right.
Hamza Farooq: So you should have an email, so, scroll down.
Hamza Farooq: To the bottom.
Andrei: I'm at the button.
Hamza Farooq: Oh, it is. Oh, so there is an email for you. I think there is an email that it wrote,
Hamza Farooq: So, if you go to, if you go to the top left on the file area.
Andrei: What?
Hamza Farooq: No, no, no, within VS Code.
Hamza Farooq: If you go to Module 2,
Hamza Farooq: There is a… the output, sorry, outputs.
Hamza Farooq: outputs.
Hamza Farooq: Yep, right-click on Preview.
Hamza Farooq: Open preview.
Hamza Farooq: So this is the email that came out.
Hamza Farooq: So this is the outcome of the email, or this is the outcome of just the recap skill that we created, from the transcript of the first class that we… whether this is transcript 1 or 2.
Verda Batool (Co-Facilitator): To… Difficulty.
Andrei: Hamza still a second.
Hamza Farooq: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: So you basically have the second class we just had, so this is the… this is last week, the class we had. You can see, the things we actually covered, the announcement and instructions, recordings, and all that, and next steps that you should follow.
Hamza Farooq: Right? So, again, you could write it as a prompt, but imagine you have 4 or 5 different skills running.
Hamza Farooq: You can now stitch 4 or 5 different skills, and I'll… we'll explain you in just one minute what those other skills are.
Hamza Farooq: But imagine if you just have one run, and it… maybe your, you know, 10 different prompts are run all together at the same time. That is what your skill will start doing for you.
Aishwarya Ashok: I think Abhi also had a question. As we cover about skills. She had a question on Slido, which is, let's say you're building a chatbot and a user puts their own prompt, can that trigger a skill?
Aishwarya Ashok: This absolutely depends on how you have the system behind scenes to be. In the sense, if the part of the skill that you're defining is to take the user's input and to be able to run
Aishwarya Ashok: a task through that, then you can orchestrate it in such a way that the skill takes the user's message, and then the skill runs in the background. For example, an example here is we have the whole aspect of
Aishwarya Ashok: having a debrief, which is to take… as soon as somebody asks what is the input here, it takes the input and then gives you an output. So the user's message is taken, and then a skill runs behind scenes to give you the output. So, this totally depends on if you want to orchestrate it based on the input.
Aishwarya Ashok: Or if you have the skill to be placed at a certain task or a process level, then it would be kick-started at that moment. And if you're individually trying it as a user, then you do a slash command and invoke that skill.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, so, and then if you wanna, put a check on, step 2, step 2,
Hamza Farooq: I think you can also see step 3. This is usually available in the terminal on how much it costs. Verda… if you can also add how we can see this in the chat, we can… people can see, you know, how much… how much does it cost to run that, in that. So, let's do, let's put a check on that.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, and we scroll down, and you can play this video also, it'll tell you,
Hamza Farooq: So, your entire transcript is now sitting in the main session.
Hamza Farooq: And it's taken a lot of context, it has a lot of… it has taken up a lot of context, it has a lot of information on it.
Hamza Farooq: So, what we did is that we took one skill, we've taken one skill so far, and we have created, things out of it, which is basically, we took… we created a recap email. Whether… there is more, is there another skill in this list, or we just directly go to sub-agents over here?
Verda Batool (Co-Facilitator): We can go to sub-agents, and then, sub-agents also use a few other skills, so that's part of the lesson, too.
Hamza Farooq: So, let's just do one thing, let's go to sub-agents, and I just want to pick up one more skill.
Hamza Farooq: And then we'll switch gears. I don't want you guys to worry about what subagent is, but, if… is there a skill here? Let's go scroll down.
Hamza Farooq: This is your FAQ writer,
Andrei: formatting skills?
Hamza Farooq: Let's just take a look… Adding the format, yes.
Aishwarya Ashok: the HTML, beautiful HTMS.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, let's… let's hold on to them, because this is gonna get a little more complex, and we don't want to, sort of, muddy the ground, but…
Hamza Farooq: So, first off, Andrea, thank you so much for taking us this far. You can add… you can add as many skills as you want, and you can trigger them together, you can trigger them independently, but they are, you know, they…
Hamza Farooq: The… what's the point of using a skill? The point of using a skill?
Hamza Farooq: is to automate a lot of your work that you know the expected outcome of, and you can expedite things moving. So, it's not one prompt that you want to run, maybe if you want to run 5 prompts together.
Hamza Farooq: It's basically, it's easier to stitch them together and run them together, rather than doing them independently.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, having said that,
Hamza Farooq: We want to switch gears. We will… we want to cover the topic on subagents. One thing is we have, a speaker from our last cohort and current FD quote. He's with us. He'll take us through… he, we want to give him… give… show you guys what he built.
Hamza Farooq: But before we get into that, I want to do one quick thing with you guys,
Hamza Farooq: I wanna show you…
Hamza Farooq: I want to do a run on sub-agents before we actually get into the session. So, there is a sub-agent which we built that I use for writing my articles.
Hamza Farooq: Now, we'll explain you what this is, and what it does, and how it works.
Hamza Farooq: But what I want from you guys, before we set the tone, I want a topic for an article.
Hamza Farooq: So anyone who, like… and it's gonna be… it will show you the outcome, so I'll show you that usually when we write an article, this is, we have a pretty deep, article that comes out of it, and, you know, it explains everything. Like, it researches, it breaks it down, it goes through the internet, does a bunch of things.
Hamza Farooq: So, can you… can one of you give me a topic that we should cover, that you would like to see an article on?
Hamza Farooq: It could be any, any, any topic, in the AI world, in,
Hamza Farooq: whatever we want to cover. So let's just say, Rupa, you want to talk about.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, graduates.
Hamza Farooq: Guardrails… An in-depth overview.
Hamza Farooq: Alright? And then this… let's just say, guardrails…
Hamza Farooq: what they are… Rupert, do you want to tell us more?
Rupa Bala: Yeah, so guardrails, what they are, what kind of problems
Rupa Bala: you should… I mean, based on the problem you're trying to solve, what are the things you need to watch out for? In other words, like, I was running, you know, I was doing my work yesterday, and I realized that, Claude was asking me for all these permissions, access to Chrome, access to this, access to that, and I was like, hang on for a second, like, I didn't think through this problem completely.
Rupa Bala: So that kind of a thing about…
Rupa Bala: As you start off with planning your test harness.
Rupa Bala: What kind of guardrails do you typically want to think about? Permission sets you want to give?
Rupa Bala: Do you want to set it up on a, you know, on a Docker container?
Rupa Bala: what… how much access you want to give, those kinds of things, would be helpful.
Hamza Farooq: So, there are two things about a guardrail. Guardrail is also for internal, and guardrail is also when you build customer products.
Hamza Farooq: All right.
Hamza Farooq: And then we're gonna say, this is my Zoom intar. So I'm gonna let it run, and I'm not gonna show you anything before that, like, what it does and how it does.
Hamza Farooq: But when the outcome comes out of it, you will be able to see what it looks like. So, we're gonna pause here, we're gonna shift gears, Aishwarya, I'm gonna let you take over, introduce elie, and then we'll let him take us through.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yes. So folks, before we move on to looking into the aspects of how to build a sub-agent, we thought it would be great to bring in Ellie, who is with us, as Hamza said, in a couple of our previous cohorts.
Aishwarya Ashok: And, he's one of those folks, one of you all, who keeps building out a lot of the projects, and what he built, very recently called Recall was very interesting for us, because it was a proper orchestration of skills, subasions, and if not for anything, a lot around evals. So.
Aishwarya Ashok: you get to track with him in this session, yes, but we also have a podcast that we recorded with Ellie on covering his entire end-to-end of how he built this out through the courses, which is available for you on your Maven resource as well, in case you're curious to know how the entire build went through. But then, here's Ellie to sort of, like, share his
Aishwarya Ashok: Thoughts with us, especially around how building sub-agents and how building evals had helped him with, recall.
Aishwarya Ashok: Hey, elie. Thank you for being here.
Aishwarya Ashok: I mean, you're speaking something, but…
elie bassil: Hey, do you hear me?
Hamza Farooq: There you go.
elie bassil: Hi, everyone, how are you?
elie bassil: So yeah, as Aisha said, I actually did this project during my previous cohort with Hamza. It was an idea that I wanted to do a very long time ago, and then in one of the classes, Hamza asked, what are you most interested in about RAG? And I remembered I answered, I'm interested about video RAG. And then I saw Hamza's eyes, like…
elie bassil: Highlight, in some way, and
elie bassil: And then I decided to build this project. So it was a project I wanted to build a very long time ago. I'm gonna explain first the business need of the project. So it's called recall. Recall solves a common problem for us knowledge workers, right? You know, we all have meetings, we all complain about meetings, but they actually matter. And the thing is, I mean, meetings are where requirements become clear, it's where people map requirements and everything else, but
elie bassil: they reveal something else as well, and it's people. And I always found that in meetings, what we always lose context of is people.
elie bassil: in your knowledge of meetings, you have all these, you know, recordings and tools, like Read.ai and other. They're very much specific within the context of every single meeting, and they don't have the history of the company, the history of the client, the history of the people, and the history of relationships.
elie bassil: So that's where the idea came from, and basically, it came from as a… like a trade-off between the AI note-takers, where speed without neons matters, and the human memory, where neons without scale. So basically, instead of having one meeting at a time, you kind of analyze all the meetings in one project summary. Instead of having static notes, we have context-aware notes and summaries, instead of having normal
elie bassil: memory of people who have stakeholder profiles across time, and a timeline of topics, and the relationships that are mapped between the people in the meeting.
elie bassil: So the idea is to know what happened, and know who matters and why.
elie bassil: Projects do not lose information, they lose people context, so people are the memory behind this system. You ask the project and you understand the person, so it kind of keeps memory of the entire project within the different meetings, within the project.
elie bassil: And it identifies all this. So it identifies the meetings, recordings, transcripts, summaries, actions, and decisions, the actual people participating in the meeting, so their roles, their behaviors, their opinions. It identifies topics and themes, it identifies relationship between people, and it analyzes relationships between people, and how the relationship evolves across different meetings. And obviously, every single evidence is linked to a specific part within the video recording.
elie bassil: of the meeting, and I'm gonna show you this now.
elie bassil: So the idea is we have several projects, we can add any project we want.
elie bassil: When we add a certain project, we can then upload meetings on this project. I'm not creating MCPs with Zoom and other, but here it's still a direct upload of a video.
elie bassil: Once you upload a video, it extracts all the transcript, and then you can identify speakers. Identifying speakers will automatically assign voices to known voices within the project directory. So it says, speaker E, voice match looks like this person.
elie bassil: And you have the video here, you can watch the entire video, you can also filter by speaker names, and then listen to what they're saying in a specific instance within the video, and then tag the voices to the actual participants.
elie bassil: And then you can obviously process the meeting. Once the meeting is processed, you'll have the different minutes of meeting. I'll show you actually here, so let's take an example, that's one.
elie bassil: So once you process the meeting, you have the minutes and the themes, you have every single decision that was taken within the meeting, but everything is… everything is obviously linked to a specific part within the meeting that can be watched.
elie bassil: And that can be listened to. I'm trying not to play everything, because this is actually a real client meeting. So basically, every single time you click on play here, you can watch the specific section within the video to kind of back your claim within the video. There are notable quotes as well. Another interesting feature is the chat feature.
elie bassil: And I have it open here somewhere. Okay, so the chat feature allows you to search within the entire meeting, so the example here is what was Jason's feedback on knowledge management. It'll give you the answer, and again, within every single answer, it'll allow you to watch the specific part within the meeting, where this was said.
elie bassil: And then it actually proposes, that's a new feature, but it actually understands from the question whether you need more, so it tells you, one, the complete dossier, and you can generate a dossier.
elie bassil: So given that this is a question on feedback, then the dossier will actually give you all the different feedback of the client on this specific theme, right? And then again, you can watch the minutes of meeting and go to the video. Relationship, or people first.
elie bassil: So people is where you will have the client and the agency people. So these are different people. You can click on a certain person, so let's say Matthew.
elie bassil: And Matthew, I have his style, so direct, structured, data-driven, the proposition, and the meeting role. I have how he reacts to process and resourcing, and then I have a history of all the meetings. I think I chose Matthew as a bad example, let me choose Summit.
elie bassil: So yeah, so I have how they react to specific topics, I have different topics, I have a timeline of their sentiment.
elie bassil: Across the different topics, across different meetings, and again, everything is linked to something specific that you can watch.
elie bassil: And then, I have here the themes, so holistic review session, project management, knowledge management, etc. Relationship is the relationship between people within meetings. So this is the graph of relationship. I can filter by meetings and by topic.
elie bassil: And let me show you an example of a relationship, so if I take,
elie bassil: I think this one has enough. So Nura and Simit are two people. I can see their interaction signals, so how often they agree, how often they don't. I can see how the feedback, what are the detailed exchanges between them. And again, I can watch every single exchange. So I can watch every single exchange, and then I can even have…
elie bassil: at the bottom, so these are all the exchanges, and I can have how the relationship evolved across time.
elie bassil: given certain specific topics, right? Topics is just the different topics, so I just lists the topics across all the meetings, who engaged, how the sentiment went.
elie bassil: And finally, a forecast is something that I'm testing now, which is you upload any document, and it tries to forecast how people would react to that document, based on the different meetings.
elie bassil: Now, of course, I have a few things that I'm still building on the project. One of them is… well, first of all, I'm testing local models, because I'm actually in talks with a specific government client, and they want local models, so I'm testing everything on local models. Obviously, the evaluations are much more difficult, so I'm trying Quen… I'm trying all sorts of local models to see which one works.
elie bassil: And hopefully, I mean, I'm starting to get there, it's a little bit difficult, but I'm starting to get there.
elie bassil: Using local models.
elie bassil: And, another feature, obviously, is the MCP that I will try, and then, I have another feature that I won't say, but yeah, I'm developing 3 new features on this.
elie bassil: So, in summary, that's it. Now, in terms of what I did, to do all this, I have a small summary here.
elie bassil: So, it's all based on sub-agents, there's no real multi-agent work here. We have the ingestion agent, we have the speaker tagger that tags speakers, the profiler that produces minutes and profiles, the retrieval agent for the chat interface, and then the forecaster agent.
elie bassil: For the ingest agent, obviously a lot of inspiration from Hamza's GitHubs, and thank you very much, Hamza, for this, like, this was…
elie bassil: Amazing.
elie bassil: But I have the, you know, I used FFMPG, Whisper, Pionote, and then being aligning, and then semantic chunks, chunk enrich, embed, and using Quadrant, again, based on Hamza's recommendation. I used to use Pinecone and pay a lot of money.
elie bassil: So that's much better now. And then… and then the… the speaker tagger agent, again, uses the transcript, name match, it's just fuzzy matching, voice print match, and then asks the user the…
elie bassil: Interesting one is the retrieval. That's the only one that's a little bit complex. It does have a router, where it checks if the answer is simple and factual, then it does self-query, decomposing, and hybrid search and re-rank on the easier path.
elie bassil: If it's an open-ended and multi-hub question, then there's a retrieval analyst that does planning, execution, and replanning.
elie bassil: So it's sort of like a deep search, deep research, but it depends on the question, because I want to try to keep the costs constrained. So if the question is easy, it's a simple workflow, and if the question is a little bit more complex, then this is where it triggers the second agent, which is the deep research agent.
elie bassil: And finally, for the evaluations, and I'm actually still evaluating a lot.
elie bassil: Especially when I… actually, when I deployed the project, I'm evaluating even more, so it's now on Fly.io. I might eventually move it to Azure for data residency, so that's what I'm working on now. But for now, I'm testing on Fly.io. So I actually came up with actual golden Q&As, and I came up with 35 real questions.
elie bassil: the first part of the questions, I had 11 only that succeeded, and then I kept evaluating to increase that to 97%.
elie bassil: I created trick questions as well from the meetings I attended, and then I was able to enhance the score. I had specific clips that I had tagged, so I watched clips, I trimmed clips, and I tried to specifically manually tag the names and the people that appear on the clips.
elie bassil: Voices and names, so it's the right name on each voice. I also did this manually, and then created the NLM as a judge, and then I had a few other. And this is,
elie bassil: Yeah, that's it, and I'm happy to answer to any question. That's the code.
elie bassil: It's all here. That's the local one, obviously, but yeah, happy to answer any question.
Hamza Farooq: First off, I… I really love what you've done.
Hamza Farooq: I think what you've done is that you've replaced
Hamza Farooq: a lot of note-taking, like, not only you've replaced Granola, not only you have replaced Read.ai.
Hamza Farooq: You've actually built something which is… Completely local to a company.
Hamza Farooq: So, you've taken away the part when… where your data is shared with another provider.
Hamza Farooq: You know, even OpenAI and Cloud and all that for that matter, and then it all stays locally.
Hamza Farooq: Which is a big achievement, right? Like, in the sense that you not only built a product, you took multi-million of… I think, I don't know how much granola is valued at, but, granola is valued an insane amount of money.
Aishwarya Ashok: Only for summary, too.
Aishwarya Ashok: Mostly for summary, but yeah, sure, it's a little more than that.
Hamza Farooq: So, how many of you actually use note takers in your company? Or, you know, they are part of your ecosystem right now?
Hamza Farooq: And you will see that, you know, some of you might use it, some of them, but a lot of corporations that we go with, right, that we work with, they are like, we have not used any… like, we use it, but we don't know what happened, and, you know, we have to get contracts. This is a great way to build a product.
Hamza Farooq: That stays within your ecosystem and doesn't get, like… this is something that we would raise money for.
Hamza Farooq: But I don't know if you want to raise money for just, you know, just say, hey, go to a company and say, we have this product that runs completely local, on your system, across your teams.
Hamza Farooq: And you can have a shared memory code also behind it.
Hamza Farooq: And I think…
Hamza Farooq: they would want to use it, because outside of US, the moment you step out of US and you go to the EU and Middle East, they don't want to use… they don't want to use
Hamza Farooq: Cloud or OpenAI. They want to use their own local models, or models which can be hosted locally, right?
elie bassil: Yes, most of them, most of them. There's a lot of, there's a lot of data residency issues as well, even in Europe, we're having this problem, even in the UK as well.
Hamza Farooq: No.
elie bassil: So they want this, they want this data residency. I'm also, I'm also adding a feature right now where you can collect feedback based on specific frames within the video, so when you share a deck.
elie bassil: It kind of takes… so it's cropping the deck, and then it gives you feedback on every slide, so that, again, things are aligned, and then I'm uploading more company context to kind of fine-tune the answers based on the company context. But I might have a few questions for you, Hamza, if you can give me some time on the local models, because I'm facing a few hurdles.
Hamza Farooq: Absolutely. I will definitely… Whoa.
elie bassil: Thank you.
Hamza Farooq: You're in the other session also, so I'll work with you on that. So we have a couple of questions from Chandrey, at least. Chandrey said, you know, how are you handling storage, given there are so many meetings? How are you collating the signals from different meetings for people? Also, how are you working when
Hamza Farooq: This is not running on your machine, but someone else runs a meeting. Like, you… are you in every meeting, so that's why you're able to capture it?
Hamza Farooq: Or are you working with, you know, you're installing it in different team… on different team members' ecosystem, so they all can learn that
Hamza Farooq: They can all can use it and have a shared stored memory.
elie bassil: Yeah, for now, we're using it in my team, so about 7 people.
elie bassil: We're testing it across, so each one of them is running it. It is deployed on Fly.io, I'm working on latency.
elie bassil: But we're all trying to access the fly.io access, which is actually here. But the only problem is we're having a bit of latency issues, so I'm working on that. And again, every time we add more to the… this is the deployed version.
elie bassil: So every time we add more to the… to the evaluation. The thing is, I'm having to evaluate a lot, because it's a bit tricky. It's a lot of language, and voice, and video, and all of these together.
elie bassil: Yeah, so that's how we're doing it. How am I able to collate across all meetings? I mean, just simply, for now, we're just uploading the meetings, but again, eventually, eventually I'm working on MCPs to be able to connect with the meeting providers as much as possible.
Hamza Farooq: Awesome, awesome.
Hamza Farooq: I think, Chandre, do you want to ask a question? Do you want to ask your second question?
Chandreyee: Yeah, since, I mean, I understand this is, possibly built for, like, localized companies, like, depending on the need of the company. I'm thinking, like, since you have a sentiment, a persona kind of created, it kind of, you know, makes me think about more from a HR perspective, like, do you even want to have… so…
Chandreyee: Have you thought of a persona, right, that you… some of these details that you are possibly producing, and it will poss… evalu… it will… it is going to evolve, depending on the equation between, people, right? Have you thought about it, like, how do you want to expose that?
Chandreyee: Or if there's an… I mean, what is the requirement that you are working with?
elie bassil: For whom? Exposed HR, you said? Sorry.
Chandreyee: this relationship, right, from… between people to people, right? It can also evolve, right? I have a certain relation with you versus somebody else, right? Is…
Chandreyee: what… how are you working towards that, like, in terms of exposing the, yeah, this… this particular thing, yeah? Is it targeted mostly from HR perspective, leadership perspective?
elie bassil: No, for now, for now, it's purely targeted on a client relation, so it's a relationship between agency and client, or between people themselves, right? And it takes into account the topics that are within a project.
elie bassil: And it shows how the relation is evolving across the clients, because this is a real pain point. I mean, I… I actually… the idea of recall came because I was handed over a project, which is a call center… this is the project, actually, that you see here. It's a call center transformation. Documentation was lost, the previous leadership didn't do much on it.
elie bassil: And we could feel that the relationship is very good, but the devil is in the details, right? The relationship, usually the first expression of how a relationship with a client is going are meetings. But it's in the fine prints. You need to be available personally to capture that, right? So the relationship part is to map this. It's really to try and understand what are the signals in the relationship that can make a relationship go sour, and then what are specific topics that can
elie bassil: Take a client off.
elie bassil: Now, to your question on HR, I honestly didn't think about it yet, but I do think that there's a lot of things that can be done, even in terms of training the team. So, teams are presenting, right? And then you have how people are reacting to their presentations, how even the sentiment is evolving across time. So, to your point, yes, this can grow a lot.
elie bassil: But for now, I'm focusing on this, which is already very complicated. But I know that the… and thank you very much, because I think it's a good idea, even. It's, it can grow a lot, yes.
elie bassil: So yeah, it's definitely something that I'll keep in mind, because when you have the history of people across many projects, it's, yeah.
elie bassil: There's a lot of things you can benefit from, yeah.
Hamza Farooq: Alright.
Aishwarya Ashok: We have a couple of more questions. Yeah, I think one around, have you received pushback on privacy-related issues? Not yet.
elie bassil: Not yet, but we could. We could receive issues on privacy. But yeah, this is something that we take, I mean, one by one with clients, right? Some clients might not like this. So, I mean, eventually, I think the trickiest one is the relationship part, and the people part.
elie bassil: Which could be tricky, right? The chat, I think nobody cares, the topics, nobody cares, the dossier, nobody cares. But on relations and sentiments, yeah.
elie bassil: Yeah, because at the end of the day, the system is sort of drawing a psychological map of people, right? Because you can see how they agree, how they disagree, how their sentiments evolve across the topics. So that's something we need to be careful about.
Hamza Farooq: I wonder if you should put our Zoom calls in that, like, actually course conversations or things, or something associated with office hours into it, and see how we get to a point.
Hamza Farooq: I mean, Read.ai is doing a lot of this, whether you guys like it or not. Read.ai is storing a lot of that information, and they're showing you that.
elie bassil: The sentiments, yeah.
Hamza Farooq: Whether you can turn it off or not, that's up to you, and…
Hamza Farooq: The tougher thing is that it's ba- so…
Hamza Farooq: You know, in US, you have a way of talking. In India, you have a way of talking. In Middle East, you have a way of talking. In Europe, you have a way of talking.
Hamza Farooq: And sometimes the US way of talking and conversation is very different from, where English is not the primary language.
elie bassil: Hmm.
Hamza Farooq: And I think a lot of these tools are unable to understand that
Hamza Farooq: A bit of a stress or tension when you're speaking in a different language.
Hamza Farooq: And it's because these tools are built on a bias.
Hamza Farooq: of overly shared data, which is predominantly English, and which is predominantly US-based English.
Hamza Farooq: Right? So I think that… some of that tinkering is also needed, right? If you…
elie bassil: Yeah, I absolutely agree. I mean, to be honest, the most difficult one is also the British language, because in British, there are lots of jokes, there are lots of dark comedy as well, so I've noticed
elie bassil: with specifically British attendees, it's a little bit difficult, because they speak in a lot of metaphors, so these are things that I'm trying to evaluate as well.
Hamza Farooq: Yay.
elie bassil: Balae.
Aishwarya Ashok: And I like how you had built out a complete data set of questions and human-labeled system, which we were just talking about at the start of the session as well.
elie bassil: Which is, like, a good example.
elie bassil: Yeah, yeah, no, I was telling you in the podcast, I mean, essentially, it took me 20% of the time to build the product and 80% to do the evals, and now I would say even more, now even more. This is when I give the count to Aishwarya during the podcast. Now it's only about evals. Everything I do is evals. I'm not building anymore.
elie bassil: Yeah, because if I don't…
Hamza Farooq: Because you don't solve every single problem, but the problems you solve, you have to do with them correctly.
elie bassil: Right? Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: Not what you build, like, you don't have to build 20,000 features, you have to build 5 features.
Hamza Farooq: But the 5 features have to work and solve a problem so well, which only you can grow from evals.
elie bassil: Hmm.
Hamza Farooq: Right? Alright, couple more questions, then we'll switch. Can you explain how you decided your chunking and database strategy? I think we should take this as a longer question, because this requires more thinking around the chunking possibility. But if you want to go maybe 30 seconds on it, you know the chunking and database and all that.
elie bassil: Yeah, of course. I mean, for database, I use Superbase, and I use Quadrant. For chunking, let me check, I think I have it here somewhere.
elie bassil: There's the chunking part.
elie bassil: Let's needs to be refreshed.
elie bassil: Yeah, it's a complex question, I can speak for hours about this.
elie bassil: But, where was the chunking?
elie bassil: Here. Yeah, so I used semantic chunk for a few. It's a question that will take time, maybe we should have another session.
elie bassil: Because, because again, there are, like, 5 sub-agents, and each one of them has their own chunking, chunking approach. So I think we need to maybe,
elie bassil: I'm not sure I have a lot of time still, right? Not how much time?
Hamza Farooq: No, we can… we can cover it, like, I'd like for you to come back with it later, so that, you know, we can… we can cover that in… in detail. We don't… we just don't want one simple answer.
elie bassil: Yeah, it will take time, because, I mean, I did a lot of search vectors and a lot of chunking, obviously, across the board, across… each one of them has their own as well, so yeah.
elie bassil: It's a rack system, basically, to be honest, all of it. It's,
Hamza Farooq: It's a highly ego drag… drag system.
Hamza Farooq: Alright,
Aishwarya Ashok: alumni.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, one last thing, how about authentication? Not all meetings is relevant to all in the org. Like, so role-based access control. I love it because we talked about it in the other class yesterday.
elie bassil: Yeah, I'm implementing rule-based access.
elie bassil: I'm implementing Rupa also work on single sign-on as well, across the board with Auth0. So it's not there yet, because now I'm focusing more on the features, but eventually, yes. For now, the project that we selected, everybody has the same rights on the project.
elie bassil: Because I want to focus on the accuracy of the information.
elie bassil: But yes, eventually I will need to have very granular rule… and rule-based access is actually interesting when it comes to regulations, as you were saying now. The more granular we can go with rule-based, the better as well. So that's something we need to think about.
Hamza Farooq: Right, awesome.
Hamza Farooq: Lee, so, elie, what is your background, and how much experience did you have in RAG before building this? I really like that question.
Hamza Farooq: highlight our course.
elie bassil: That's a good question. To be honest, I have a background of computer science, but I stopped 10 years ago.
elie bassil: And I moved to the business world, and then I stopped any sort of coding, so I was very behind. I have a background in Python, but I was very behind. So, when I got back to this world, and obviously AI and coding came back, I started learning web coding.
elie bassil: To be honest, I would say, I mean, I started all this probably, like, a few months before having taken the class with you. And honestly, the things that I learned during the classes with you were huge. It's just that I put… I really put a lot of effort, so the previous, I think it was the FDE class, if I'm not mistaken.
elie bassil: The previous cohort of FDE, I took it on myself to, like, really relearn Python, and I was going with the class, and I was building the workshop in parallel, and yeah, and I mean, with Vibe coding, everything becomes much easier, but it's all about, again, it's all about evaluating and understanding the architecture.
Hamza Farooq: Awesome. Well, thank you so much, thank you.
elie bassil: Thank you for having me.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, it was always good to bring you on and, like, see how you've built all of these things through, so thank you so much.
elie bassil: No, thank you for the inspiration. Honestly, this was all started, like.
elie bassil: at the beginning of the FDE class, this whole project, and then I was… I presented it in the capstone, so you can imagine how much you inspired me, so thank you so much, really.
Hamza Farooq: Awesome.
elie bassil: to come.
Hamza Farooq: Yeah, and those of you who are like, you know, what is FD? FD is the Forward Deployment Engineering course. This is the other course we teach. Some of you are also in that course, so you guys know about it, but the whole idea is that you don't…
Hamza Farooq: we want to build it up in a way that you take one course, and then if you feel comfortable, you should take the other, but… because that other course is extremely technical and requires a lot more hands-on building as we go. I think, elie, you have been taking that course again, and you've probably seen that we have changed a lot of things in that one also.
elie bassil: Yes, even the first assignment was very interesting compared to the other one. We had the Chrome module the first round, this time we had, like, this perplexity duplicate, and it was all about evaluation, which I enjoyed as well.
Hamza Farooq: Yes.
elie bassil: Really good, yeah. But I took, I took Claude, Claude, Claude… I took a class with you before FDE, which was Claude Work or something, Claude…
Hamza Farooq: Cloud code in practice. Yeah, Cloud Code in practice.
elie bassil: Yes, I've been with you for a year. I'm not, I'm not letting go. Every single course…
Hamza Farooq: that takes time, but then once you… you just have to put in the effort towards it, you know? All I tell people is that, you know, put your effort in it, and eventually you'll get to a place where you feel very comfortable doing so.
elie bassil: Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, awesome. elie, thank you so much.
elie bassil: Pleasure.
Hamza Farooq: Alright. So, Aishwarya, over to you. Let's start talking about the…
Hamza Farooq: the sub-agent part, and I think.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yes.
Hamza Farooq: now that we have everybody prepared with skills, we'll… we'll get… we'll move much faster. Verda if you can also paste the…
Hamza Farooq: the GitHub URL, if you want to paste, if you could paste the GitHub URL, what we can do is we can show one more skill, just quickly, or… or actually, actually, Aishwarya, let's start with this, and then we'll… we can come back.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, yeah, I think now that people have seen elie's projects on how exactly he used sub-agents, and he brought in the word as well, I think we'll start with understanding the movement from skills to sub-agents, and then continue with both what Hamza had you all give as a topic, and then there's a blog system that's running behind, as well as the skill setup that we need for you folks.
Aishwarya Ashok: So,
Aishwarya Ashok: In terms of automation, where we are, or how we have done so far, is the first level, which is using skills. We identified the patterns, we identified tasks that can have skills in order to run them more efficiently. And in the next days and the next class, we're going to look into two other forms of automation. So one is the subhitans, and the other one is
Aishwarya Ashok: an agent team, and there's a subtle nuance between the two. You learn about them as we go, but from moving from a skill to a sub-agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: it's important to know what a sub-agent actually lets you do. So, we saw that for skill, it is helping you turn a task into a command. Basically, for a task, you have a set of instructions, and then you turn that into a skill in order to run it every single time you want to call that skill.
Aishwarya Ashok: A sub-agent is a form of a worker.
Aishwarya Ashok: And think of it as a process. So the minute you know that your process is slightly complex, and it can actually not just have
Aishwarya Ashok: only one skill run, but then you need to have that agent being able to work together with a couple of other agents, then the sub-agent concept enters into picture. So, sub-agent is a worker that, if you give your main agent a task.
Aishwarya Ashok: Then what the main agent would do is call that independent worker that would actually do that job for you. And provided that job is going to be complex, it's going to involve a process of its own.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, the simplest thing of an example could be, let's say, you want to research, you want to go ask Claude, can you come up with 3 competitor, examples for me?
Aishwarya Ashok: What is happening today in the behind scenes is that your main Cloud agent is doing the job of using tools, going and fetching the detail for you, and then giving the result to you on the screen as a single agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: And if you have a skill to perform a certain task, the same agent is going and invoking the skill, and then doing the job, and then giving the output on the screen for you.
Aishwarya Ashok: A sub-agent is a slightly different in terms of working. So when you ask your main agent the task of research three competitors for me.
Aishwarya Ashok: If you have a sub-agent called research agent, then the main agent, think of it as a teacher agent. The teacher agent is going to call the student agent, which is the research sub-agent, and that agent is going to run independently of the main chat.
Aishwarya Ashok: It's gonna finish the task, and then give back the answer to the main agent to say, here is what you request.
Aishwarya Ashok: So…
Aishwarya Ashok: almost like a branching that you can think of. So, so far, what we've been doing with Claude is ask a question, ask it to do a job, the main agent does the entire work and hands over the output to you. A sub-agent is invoked
Aishwarya Ashok: Whenever there is a complex process that you want to handle, and when you ask the main agent, the main agent calls the sub-agent to complete the task, gives it all the context that it needs.
Aishwarya Ashok: waits for that sub-agent to independently run and give an output back to the main agent, such that it can return the summary or return the output to you. So subagents are independent workers, or think of them as contractors, that the main agent is basically pulling in whenever there is a pattern match.
Aishwarya Ashok: Very similar to the skill, where when you call a skill, when you ask for a slash command and call a skill, a skill is invoked.
Aishwarya Ashok: Very similarly, you ask the main agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: For a certain task, and you have a sub-agent for it, the sub-agent gets invoked and independently handles all those tasks for you.
Aishwarya Ashok: Then let's look at what actually constitutes when there is a subagent and when there is no subagent.
Aishwarya Ashok: So when there is no sub-agent, if the process is extremely complex, like.
Aishwarya Ashok: even research for that matter, let's say it has to go research about 100 links. So when you ask for 3 competitors, and there are, like, 100 links that is happening in the background, without a sub-agent, the problem is that your main agent is going to do the hard job of 100 tool calls. It's going to keep multiple tool calls, it's going to go fetch all of that information, so your main agent is sort of stuck in that window to execute on that task before it can give you an output.
Aishwarya Ashok: But when you think of setting up a sub-agent for this job, which is a research agent whose job or task is whenever the user asks for research, the main agent can automatically depend on this contractor sub-agent for it to run the entire job of going and fetching those links.
Aishwarya Ashok: It happens independently out of your main context window, main agent window, which means your main agent is not overwhelmed, your main agent is not
Aishwarya Ashok: handling that tedious task of doing all of the job by itself. It's kind of outsourcing what it is supposed to do to a specializer, or to a specialized sub-agent that can go and finish the task.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yes, Hamza.
Hamza Farooq: I always give food examples, so I'll give you guys a food example. Imagine you're cooking, you have a kitchen, and you want somebody to slice and dice your onions and your vegetables. So, if that person stays in your kitchen, and you know, is just doing everything right in front of you, using your resources and everything.
Hamza Farooq: Versus, you say, hey, I want you to cook the meat, I want you to slice and dice, and I want you to give me a half-baked product. Go do on your own time, on your own resources, and independently, in your own area.
Hamza Farooq: That's what a sub-agent is. Sub-agent, you outsource the whole thing.
Hamza Farooq: To an independent machine, or independent context that never interacts with you until it's finished.
Hamza Farooq: Whereas a skill is doing it right in front of you, using all the information that you have. So let's say the temperature you have, the material you have, everything that you have, it uses right over there. The sub-agent goes off on a different tangent and builds it on its own, and only comes back when it's done
Hamza Farooq: exactly what you want… what you have asked, to a certain degree, and then says, this is what I've done based on all my resources. I did not use any of your resources, so we have a divide-and-conquer relationship.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, and resource here is… think of it from the context window perspective as well. So when the table becomes messy with a lot of ingredients, and everything is happening in the same size, same table, then the main agent's context window, the main agent's working, is disturbed. It's just so full that the output, what you want, is not
Aishwarya Ashok: Really the efficient form of what you want to get.
Aishwarya Ashok: Versus if the sub-agent independently goes off to the other room, finishes all of it from its own context window, from its own workings, and then gets back with just what the main agent needs, with just the ingredients that would be needed, the final output of the sliced diced onions that it would need to put into the dish, then that is the version that it uses its own resource, own format, own way of running.
Aishwarya Ashok: And then hands over just what the main agent needs, because the user has asked for a certain input.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, that is the difference between with and without a sub-agent. So, with a sub-agent, the process gets much more streamlined. Your context window is not overwhelmed, so your main agent does not have to get overwhelmed. It can outsource that job to another sub-agent when available to get that job done.
Aishwarya Ashok: And if you remember the .clot folder that we saw, we saw that skills are housed under a skills folder, so anytime you ask Clot to create a sub-agent for you.
Aishwarya Ashok: it automatically puts it under an agents folder in your .clot folder. So the structure is such a way that it automatically gets added, your subagents get added into your agent folders.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, what makes that sub-agent different from a skill, right? Like, both of them are .MD files, like Markdown files. So, a sub-agent, as the name, can sound like it's an agent entirely. What triggers it underneath is also a markdown file, so it's just a construct of a couple of fields that matter.
Aishwarya Ashok: Starting with the two fields that are very, very similar to what you did with the skill as well, which is the name and description, because this is almost like your must, you know, requisite of sorts, because the way in which your main agent can go call a skill or call a sub-agent is only when it understands
Aishwarya Ashok: the name and the purpose for which this particular sub-agent is going to be useful for. So, the name and the description becomes the trigger.
Aishwarya Ashok: The additional element that we make for a sub-agent is also, because it is able to go use its own resource, use its own way of doing things, you also give it the next four set of fields, which is the model.
Aishwarya Ashok: The tools, the memory, and the skills.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, model is the fact that because it's independently operating, you can have the main agent that still operates in an Opus, but you can have the sub-agent's model defined as Fable, or you can have the sub-agent's model defined as salt, depending on what you want that definition to be. So, every sub-agent that you define can have its own resource, can have its own model, where, depending on the task, if it's going to be a deep
Aishwarya Ashok: research task, you give it Opus. If it's going to be very standard, normal, sort of neutral tasks, then you have Sonnet, or if you want to give a slightly
Aishwarya Ashok: you know, lesser model, then you can give a Haiku. It all depends on how you want to level set the resource for that particular task.
Aishwarya Ashok: Same to do with tools. So we saw how Research Agent is all about going and fetching links, and going and reading what's in the web. So, obviously, the tools that would be needed here would be the web access. You need to have the web crawling tool, the web fetching tool.
Aishwarya Ashok: Versus, we're going to quickly see in a bit of time how that block system worked, because for a block system, you need to be able to have a researcher, you need to be able to have an editor that writes the article. So for an editor, it would not need a tool that actually needs to have web access, because all the editor is doing is just simply putting down lines after lines in a certain digestible format.
Aishwarya Ashok: So perhaps the tools there is just a writing tool, a simple write tool, versus for a reviewer, the tool is just a simple read tool.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, a sub-agent also has the flexibility to let you define what tools are permissible. So, which means, to the question that we, you know, asked at the start of the class also, which is, can agents just go drift, and then can
Aishwarya Ashok: automatically start doing things.
Aishwarya Ashok: With tool definition, the agent can only do the things that it is supposed to do. So, if your tool is only web access, then the sub-agent's role is only to use that tool and not any other tool, because it's not defined to do anything else.
Aishwarya Ashok: The next part of memory is interesting, because it is, once again, what we keep talking about. When you run subasions, the subasions output, because you're defining tools, you're defining different resources, you're defining different models, the output is going to vary from one subasian to another subasian.
Aishwarya Ashok: And between one run to another run for the same subagent itself. So, memory is how it can learn across different sessions.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, which means you can start to have a memory file that saves every subagent run, the important output that you need to get from that session, and start building over the context layer, so that you understand and build evals on top of it. You know how your subagent runs for every run, and you know the kind of output that it gives you over time that you would be able to fine-tune it much better.
Aishwarya Ashok: And last part is pretty interesting, because what you see here is your sub-agent can also use the skills. So what you've been building so far with skill, subtle nuances, a skill is for a task. A sub-agent is for a process.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, a sub-agent can also have a skill in it. So, if you've built a skill for a certain specific task.
Aishwarya Ashok: The sub-agent is doing the task, but it is also completing a process, then your skill becomes a part of that sub-agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, when you run the subagent, the .nd file, it has all of these definitions well in it, so that it even has the definition of which task to run, and which skill to call for that task.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, a name description is prerequisite. The model, tools, memory, and skills are the flexibility with which every sub-agent can have its own resources, and its own time window and own context window to run the task and give you an output.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, I'm going to pause here with this last slide, which is, like, the difference between a sub-agent and a skill. So, when do you call what? A skill, remember, the rule is always when it's a task.
Aishwarya Ashok: And when you know it's a repeatable prompt, the skill is the easiest way in which your main agent can run something and give you the output. And you do not need to have a complex process around it. The main agent still can handle that task and give you the output in the same window.
Aishwarya Ashok: Versus a sub-agent is whenever you need to run something parallel, whenever you need to run something independently, and it has a set of tasks in it, one after the other.
Aishwarya Ashok: And it actually needs to have its own resource in order to run and give you the most right output possible in an isolated and a delegated way, then you use a sub-agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: And a repeatable task is a skill. Isolated, delegatable, freelancer, contractor, agent that can help the main agent take the load off and, you know, bring back whatever context is needed, then that's sub-agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: So I'm gonna pause here, and I'm gonna look out for, like, specific questions you may have.
Aishwarya Ashok: After which, we can get into looking into the hands-on build of how a SAP agent works.
Aishwarya Ashok: Any questions that, came up in Slido?
Aishwarya Ashok: Just gonna pause here.
Hamza Farooq: How does Claude decide when to use customized sub-agents created by me versus a subagent it creates by itself automatically sometimes?
Hamza Farooq: So the way we work with this is we invoke our sub-agent to run behind the scenes. So.
Hamza Farooq: Let me… let me show you guys a great example, on what we have.
Hamza Farooq: So, can you guys all- can you all see my screen?
Hamza Farooq: Yes? So, over here… Sorry, my cough is just worse today.
Hamza Farooq: So, we had Rupa ask us a question about guardrails, you know, how do they work, what is the, you know, some of the things that we can have, and this is an article that just came out. So, today is 20th, 20th September. It wrote right while we were, you know, while we were running, it basically created an article
Hamza Farooq: And every single thing that is being done.
Hamza Farooq: is… it is done by the AI agents behind the scenes.
Hamza Farooq: So, if you see over here, all… every single image that you see, every single link that you see that was created.
Hamza Farooq: None of this is done by me. Like, I was teaching you guys, so I possibly could not do this myself. Every single thing was done by, on its own, all the images that were built.
Hamza Farooq: And, you know, it built, you know, the course overviews and other things associated with it all in one place, just from that small prompt that I gave you.
Hamza Farooq: So, Rupa, I don't know if you're here. Yeah, you're here, I see you. But this is, you know, the question you ask, and then, sort of, LLM guardrails are rule-based and model-based controls placed around language models to block harmful inputs, constrain outputs, and enforce boundaries on what systems can do at runtime.
Hamza Farooq: The protector against prompt injection, data leakage, policy violation, and unsafe tool use.
Hamza Farooq: And then it sort of gives you a key takeaway and builds it out.
Hamza Farooq: Now… you could ask ChatGPT or any AI to run this, and it will use its own sub-agents.
Hamza Farooq: It will invoke its own sub-agents to build it for you, and whatever it will do, it will look like most, in most cases, an AI slot.
Hamza Farooq: So, what you do with agents, or how do you use your own agents, or skills, is by invoking them yourself.
Hamza Farooq: So, what I did is that I built this front end over here. This front-end
Hamza Farooq: has multiple layers to it, and I'll explain to you all those layers in one second, but…
Hamza Farooq: Essentially, we have built, an entire layer on top of it, ourselves.
Hamza Farooq: And… let me just open that… that one… Where is my dogs?
Hamza Farooq: Open live server… okay. So, can you all see this one? The SEO Writer's multi-agent System?
Hamza Farooq: So this is what I have designed, and I invoke
Hamza Farooq: this SEO, or search engine optimizer, writer.
Hamza Farooq: which invokes all the agents that I've stitched together.
Hamza Farooq: So this one, you know, I introduce a topic, an intent which, Rupa, you gave, that, you know, this is what I want you to tell me.
Hamza Farooq: It…
Hamza Farooq: It basically does not even go to Cloud Code now. It's a… or does not go to the ClotQuote agents itself, it only will work through my own ecosystem that I have stitched together.
Hamza Farooq: And when you say, how do I stitch it together, it's exactly what Verda has shown you.
Hamza Farooq: So what, you know, the output that we had, the step-by-step, thing that we have been building with Verda, and she, she shared with you, and I'll open that link again.
Hamza Farooq: This is literally a step-by-step process on how you can build that. So you start with this, you set up the repo, you add skills.
Hamza Farooq: you build your sub-agent, and we'll go through this in the next session also. So you can add… you can start adding your sub-agents here. You can slowly add one… the first agent, the second agent, the third agent.
Hamza Farooq: Then you can build an agent team out of it, and then all you need to do is say, use my agent team.
Hamza Farooq: To create an output for me.
Hamza Farooq: So it sort of displaces all the things that Cloud Code offers you out of the box.
Hamza Farooq: To your own ecosystem.
Hamza Farooq: And that's where we want you to sort of gravitate towards that
Hamza Farooq: Now, instead of utilizing Clot Code Harness.
Hamza Farooq: of Claude capabilities, you're just using Claude
Hamza Farooq: model, like, the model or the LLM of Claude.
Hamza Farooq: To actually write things by yourself.
Hamza Farooq: Or create the harness yourself.
Hamza Farooq: So your harness is now the set of different sub-agents
Hamza Farooq: That you have created on your own.
Hamza Farooq: Instead of using anything that Claude offers out of the box.
Hamza Farooq: I'm gonna let that sink in. Any specific questions on this part, on how we graduate from using ClotQuote system itself?
Hamza Farooq: To actually building our own sub-agents and agents and skills to get them to work.
Hamza Farooq: Ashosh, go ahead.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yes, that's such.
Ashutosh Pandit: Yeah, so, basically…
Ashutosh Pandit: this whole thing could have been done, like, I think I even played around and say, on Cloud Code to say, this is what I want to build, make a PRD, so it automatically would have built some skills, sub-agents, and developed something, versus right now, we are more in control when we do it in this way. Is that the distinction?
Hamza Farooq: So, you… I would say that, you know, follow this… I could give a prompt to exactly what you said. I could give it… give my plot quote my transcript, and say, I want you to bill me a flashcard, I want you to bill me, you know, a bunch of things, and you want to do based on what its best knowledge is.
Hamza Farooq: Here?
Hamza Farooq: We have taken control of every single output that will come out of that ecosystem, as we did in this article.
Hamza Farooq: In which, I want you to do the research. This is how I want you to do the research.
Hamza Farooq: The next part is, this is how I want you to act as an editorial agent. Then this is how I want you to write the article.
Hamza Farooq: This is how I want you to humanize it. This is the meta-agent way of doing it. This is how I want you to build an agent. Then I want you to evaluate it, and then I want you to go back and forth in evaluating until I hit this particular score, and that's when,
Hamza Farooq: My output is ready for the world to see.
Ashutosh Pandit: But I'm gonna push a little bit here. So, for example, even with Cloud Code, couldn't we have done the same thing in terms of
Ashutosh Pandit: we see the output, be like, you know what, here I want you to modify this aspect of it and do research in this manner, and then do the writing in this manner. Slowly, slowly, sort of gravitate towards whatever you want it to be, but by iteration, you see the output. It's not exactly how you want it to be, but it's kind of giving you a first draft, and you keep improving on it and develop.
Ashutosh Pandit: Something that.
Hamza Farooq: I'll work.
Ashutosh Pandit: He wants… you want it to be there.
Hamza Farooq: what Claude people don't want you to do. They don't want you to prompt.
Hamza Farooq: They want to build reusable systems.
Hamza Farooq: This is what we call a re… I, of course, will keep updating this also, right? Like, if I get an output, I'll… but I have a better starting point.
Hamza Farooq: I have systems which are built out for me.
Hamza Farooq: And I'm gonna replace those systems only when I feel that they need to be replaced, rather than starting from scratch every single time, and this way, I'm making it a deterministic flow.
Ashutosh Pandit: Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: So, for instance, this article, as I'm showing you, what Rupa asked me to write, right?
Hamza Farooq: Tell me you can write this while you're teaching a course.
Hamza Farooq: and build all these images, and everything coherently, written in a certain way, with a very good humanizer score, all in one… zero shot. Like, I didn't even intervene. I told it to write it, and it did every single thing that I did on its own.
Hamza Farooq: Right? That's the part that we are automating. So, when he showed you his transcripts, right? Or he showed you the meeting outcome.
Hamza Farooq: You could still do it with Cloud Code, but can you build it in a repeatable way throughout the series? That's what we are going after.
Hamza Farooq: Does that make sense?
Ashutosh Pandit: Yeah, yeah, I think I got it mostly, I can call you separately, just to complete. I want to give charge to others in case they have some options, so…
Hamza Farooq: Completely.
Aishwarya Ashok: Okay, just to add one last bit to what Hamza was saying to Ashutosh's question. So, when you prompt Trotcode, and when you, you know, basically, without any sort of this setup that you have, you just say, I want to come up with a blog, and I just want to research about this topic, can you go do this for me?
Aishwarya Ashok: There is one direction in which
Aishwarya Ashok: Cloud Code's main agent is just going to do all of this job by itself, and that's why I was telling you the whole
Aishwarya Ashok: context window getting full kind of a problem happens, because your agent is overwhelmed, and unless prompted, it would not know that it needs to start, like, a subagent setup. So that is one direction in which your main agent, without any sort of knowledge on there is an orchestration, or there is a process through which you want to go do this.
Aishwarya Ashok: you're… you know, it starts doing it. And to your point, Ashosh, you're doing a back-and-forth thing with prompt.
Aishwarya Ashok: the entire context of that stays within the chat, or within that interaction, right? You are nowhere trying to, Hamza was mentioning, trying to codify that, or trying to make that as a system. So yes, you can't get to this article in, like, about 5 turns, and just telling you… telling Claude Agent that 5 times that this is exactly what I want.
Aishwarya Ashok: But it's going to stay within the context of that chat. It's not going to get to you
Aishwarya Ashok: one as a system that you can literally repurpose, and this is… in essence, this is building your own hardness, right? We keep talking about being able to build your own hardness, sort of a system. What you're doing here is literally a format of that, which is given a process, given a certain, you know, output or a certain contract, you want the entire system to run by itself with all the definitions that you'll need.
Aishwarya Ashok: So…
Aishwarya Ashok: in order for the main agent to not take the overwhelming task, and in order to not have the one chat have the context, but to have it run as a system, something like this is helpful. That's one direction. The other direction is
Aishwarya Ashok: yes, Claude can spin up their own sub-agent. Yes, Claude, if you ask Claude today, go and build out this product for me and come up with your own sub-agents. Claude is coming up in the background is only the software development side of sub-agents, which is… it will spin up a sub-agent to go create the output for you, but
Aishwarya Ashok: you cannot reuse a subagent. You cannot repurpose a sub-agent the next time you want to run something. So yes, Claude will spin up 5 sub-agents if you go ask today, to Claude Claude that, can you come up with an article, and can you spin up 5 sub-agents for me?
Aishwarya Ashok: it remains within the context of that chart. But if you build that whole 5 to 6 subagions and ask Claude to turn that up into a system as how exactly you're doing, then you can extend that further. So, your point was yes and a no, so I hope you got the difference between the yes.
Hamza Farooq: All right. One thing that came from another question is, shobhit is, let's say my sub-agent wants to use RAG as a tool, so the index of RAG will be part of sub-agent memory, or separate?
Hamza Farooq: So, shobhit will keep it independent. We'll keep the memory of your rag completely as a tool, and independent, and only invoked. So the agent does not need to have access to entire rag memory, it only needs to have access to the output of that RAG tool.
Hamza Farooq: to utilize and fork and carry it forward. You don't want to, you know, fill up your agent memory with all the RAG data in it. You want to keep it… it runs as the Markdown file, so it will continue to have that information only. That's it.
shobhit gupta: And let's say, so, the memory of the sub-agent, let's say it stores all the past outputs of that sub-agent. So, let's say in the rack there is semantic cache. So, that also will be separate, like, from this memory.
Hamza Farooq: That's completely different, and it will not store all the outcomes, it will store in the MD file the learnings from that.
shobhit gupta: Okay.
Hamza Farooq: The learnings on whether it failed at some point or not.
Hamza Farooq: Okay.
shobhit gupta: Yeah, makes sense, yeah. Thanks.
Hamza Farooq: Different things associated.
Aishwarya Ashok: That's all future.
shobhit gupta: Sure.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, when a main agent is calling different sub-agents, the main agent has literally no, you know, no breadcrumbs of what's really happening within each sub-agent. So, when the main agent calls a sub-agent, such as a reviewer agent or a writer agent.
Aishwarya Ashok: It's only within the context of that particular sub-agent would all of these processes run through. So the memory becomes a thing of that particular sub-agent, and when it gets back with an answer to the main sub-agent, think of it as a task that the teacher has given to all the students. The teacher does not know what resource, what tools, what format each student is completing it in. All they know is the student is submitting the answer. So the teacher has a
Aishwarya Ashok: collection of all the answers to present to the board to say, here are all the answers to the task that you gave the class, but the teacher does not know the amount of effort or whatever, you know, behind scenes that each student agent has actually gone and done. But when you go within the context of that sub-agent, of that student agent, you would see the student actually used
Aishwarya Ashok: 5 tools actually used an entire repository of memory to save every run, so that when tomorrow asked a question of how did you come up with this.
Aishwarya Ashok: that particular file can actually show all the runs. So, the main agent will never know what's happening within each of the sub-agents, only the output, only the input and only the output is present with the main teacher agent. The rest of it
Aishwarya Ashok: Each independent sub-agent would have its own, you know, setup by itself that it would start having the necessary details.
Hamza Farooq: And one thing is… I think that I was gonna say this, and so I'm not sure you asked the question. How do you decide between having the logic of how to write this article in backend code versus having an agent MD file?
Hamza Farooq: So, we actually have… entire thing is an AgentMD file, these are all agent.md files, these are not backend code.
Hamza Farooq: we can… we can export them and make them as MD files, agent, like, backend code files. So, Sudancho, I want to first differentiate that part.
Hamza Farooq: I'm still using agent.md. All of these are agent.md files, right? So we're utilizing the harness of Cloud Code to run, but not using the agents of Cloud Code to run.
Hamza Farooq: The second part is…
Hamza Farooq: everybody has their own way of cooking food, right? You know, again, I give food examples. Everybody has their own way of making biryani, but you have… let's say you've gotten to a part where you know exactly the every single ingredient that you want to add in every single style. So think of
Hamza Farooq: Your sub-agents and agent as a recipe.
Hamza Farooq: That you have mastered.
Hamza Farooq: And it auto-runs when you invoke it, like, every single step is done exactly the way you want.
Hamza Farooq: And 90% of the time it works, 10% of the time it will fail.
Hamza Farooq: So, first, Claude is, I want you to… you tell Claude, Claude, I want you to make biryani, Claude, Claude, and I hope everybody knows biryani here. It's a global dish now. You say, go make biryani for me, or puttered chicken for me. It will make… it's an own direction.
Hamza Farooq: And you'll keep telling it, come back to it, come back to it, come back to it. Or you say.
Hamza Farooq: Here's my logic.
Hamza Farooq: Here's my step-by-step process, every single way of how I've built it.
Hamza Farooq: every single step of the way, and then when it follows that exact pathway, you will say, okay, I'm 90% sure, or 95% sure, that it will land in this spot.
Hamza Farooq: That's what we are building over here, because we want to control every aspect of every single thing that is built.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah.
Aishwarya Ashok: And one small thing I would add to that part, what Hamza was saying, is also, some of this, as much as it looks like it's a process, so the output is still probabilistic, right? Like.
Aishwarya Ashok: it's the LLM that goes inside and takes each of these steps and completes the steps. So, what you get as the output from a research agent, which… like, what Rupa was asking, we did not deterministically know this is how the output of the subagents is going to be. Like, the article is actually going to have these words, or these paragraphs, or these aspects. That is completely probabilistic, and that's… that's still the output of any subagent that
Aishwarya Ashok: would have.
Aishwarya Ashok: the whole…
Aishwarya Ashok: thing that we're trying to give as a process, or trying to give one thing that comes after the other, is…
Aishwarya Ashok: the route or the path that the agent can take, so that you do not basically make that agent just, you know, sort of, like, ramble through the air. Instead, you're giving it direction to say, in order to complete this output, or in order to complete this loop, we need to have these steps in picture. But when you closely watch, you're not telling the agent that this is how the output should look like. So when Rupa gave us the prompt.
Aishwarya Ashok: or the basic set of input, words to this, we did not know that the output is going to have 10 images. We did not know that the output is going to have, like, 5 paragraphs, after which it's going to have something else inside.
Aishwarya Ashok: That is still the probabilistic part of the subagions.
Aishwarya Ashok: The part that you're just trying to process or codify is the route that your entire agent has to take so that
Aishwarya Ashok: you're just not making that main agent get overwhelmed and just go off the truck. That is one highlight that I wanted to make with what Hamza said. And, Arjun had a question on Slido, which is.
Aishwarya Ashok: The sub-agent is not… so, when it comes to a project, once again, you can use a sub-agent very similar to Cloud.md or skill.md. You can use a sub-agent across projects.
Aishwarya Ashok: Definitely, yes. So you can use the same subagent, the Markdown file, for both Cloud Code and for codecs, or any sort of agent that runs. So the sub-agent concept is pretty much available in most hardnesses today. So Codex hardness supports its own sub-agents, Claude hardness supports its own sub-agents, so you can have the same
Aishwarya Ashok: sub-agent to run across both Cloud Code and Codex, and yes, similar to Cloud.md and Skill.md.
Aishwarya Ashok: Again, once again, a subagent is a markdown file. If anything, we just saw that it's still a markdown file. Only thing is that it is slightly different in structure to have its own set of resources and capabilities, which is what we defined with memory, tools, model, and skills in itself.
Aishwarya Ashok: So, same.md file, but with slightly grander purpose is what a sub-agent is.
Aishwarya Ashok: Hamza, you're on mute.
Hamza Farooq: So we're gonna pause here today, and, you know, we… this is where we sort of will take over talking to you agents right from the next class. We would ask you to do one thing, is
Hamza Farooq: If nothing, just try to implement what we have given you here. Give us feedback if something doesn't sound right, doesn't read right, something, you know, doesn't… is not what you want. But what we will ask you to do is just go through this, you know, this overview, this step-by-step, so that
Hamza Farooq: If anything, just get to Lesson 2, and we'll send you an email also, so you can follow through. But just get to Lesson 2, in the next, 2-3 days, or 4 days, too, especially before the class, so that…
Hamza Farooq: You have reached a point where you have them available.
Hamza Farooq: As you start using them, you will understand, and you'll be like.
Hamza Farooq: oh, this is what… this is why I need to use these ecosystems, and you will get used to… and once you know how the structure of one works, you can start building more of them.
Hamza Farooq: And that's why you would say that… you know, because a lot of times, we are… where we resist taking on something because we don't know what it can do for you. So, this will give you the… this will sort of work so fast.
Hamza Farooq: and change the way you think about it, that you'll be like, okay, I don't… I don't know why I haven't used these before.
Hamza Farooq: So you're… you're now going from using recipes which were available out of the box in plot code.
Hamza Farooq: Building things in your own instructions so that they are more nuanced.
Hamza Farooq: and build in a way exactly that you want, rather than following a method, or, you know, like a probabilistic way that Claudecode would have done in the first place.
Hamza Farooq: Alright? And you…
Aishwarya Ashok: still not letting go of the agent's nature, that's still intact, and sorry, just one last bit is you can connect it back with both the examples that we've given here, which is the debrief that you set up, as well as going back to what he was showing us in terms of those different sub-agents that he set up. You can listen to the recording once again to now go and piece back the, the different agents that he showed as to why would, you know, you have
Aishwarya Ashok: one agent to sort of take the input. Why would you have one agent to do the profiling? One separate agent? So now the whole part of not overwhelming your main agent, not having the context window go off when especially you're giving in a lot of those transcripts makes sense. So spend some time looking into the example that we have with both debrief and looking back at what, recall that elie had built through, gave you for subagent's context.
Hamza Farooq: Awesome.
Hamza Farooq: Alright, any last questions we can help answer?
Hamza Farooq: Before we call it a day for you all.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yeah, and please bring it to the office hours as well. It is… yeah, yeah, I think I was just putting a message. We do have the podcast in case you want to listen to a full version of that, but but yeah, please do bring your questions to the office hours.
Hamza Farooq: Andrew, go ahead.
Andrew Melito: Yeah, hi, thanks. I am on Lesson 2, Step…
Andrew Melito: 6, where you run the debrief, which is… it's taking us time to do, which is seemingly going, fine. But when we're talking about using different memory and context.
Andrew Melito: I can't necessarily, within the same chat, ask something else. I want to let it run. It's just that I'm not filling up my contacts window with this chat by letting agents do the work, right? If I want to do another task, new chat, new question.
Aishwarya Ashok: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: You could append the question, it will come back to you on that question, it will come back to you eventually, but you can sort of divide and conquer, like.
Hamza Farooq: the current chat that you have is running that process. You can ask a few more things, and it will answer when it's done, or it, you know, it will give you a middle, you know, like, it will stack up your questions. But if you want to run an independent thing, you can open a new session, it will run it.
Andrew Melito: Okay, great. Now, I'm letting it to do its thing, so I'll see what it… what it produces.
Aishwarya Ashok: One of them is background processes. Like, you set up your own background processes. Yeah.
Hamza Farooq: Right? And this is… this is a pretty deep article in terms of things to cover, so…
Hamza Farooq: Again, we know, like, we can teach you everything, but you will get better when you start using and being more hands-on. elie didn't have it when you started with the session, but we sort of got to a point where we're like, we need to have something like this. So, of course, we can't build very extensive ones.
Hamza Farooq: But this is… this is an interesting place to be… to be starting.
Aishwarya Ashok: And, we'll also be doing, like, a mid-course recap, so don't worry if you're still, like, figuring out how to get started with some of these concepts as you build on. Hamza and I, we usually do, like, a mid-course recap, where we cover whatever, you know, as a revision or a way of catching up with these concepts. So right after our office hours, we'll ensure that that video is up by the end of this week, before you come to the next class.
Aishwarya Ashok: So you understand,
Aishwarya Ashok: You know, the revision of all of the concepts that we've covered across the first three modules.
Hamza Farooq: Yep.
Hamza Farooq: Awesome.
Hamza Farooq: All right, folks, thank you everyone, thank you so much. You all have a great rest of the weekend, we'll see you, we'll see you in the office hours, and then we'll see you, as a follow-up. We'll also send you a feedback form, just a mid-course feedback on
Hamza Farooq: what is your expectation? What… we have, you know, a few more classes remaining. We can always add a bonus class towards the end to cover topics that we…
Hamza Farooq: We wanted to learn, so…
Hamza Farooq: We have a lot of content, we want to be aware of your time and the videos that you can watch, because you all have lives also. But anything that you feel like, you know, what's working, what's not working, we…
Hamza Farooq: there's a drift every single batch on what is expected versus what's the outcome, and we adapt at this point. We want… we will adapt to what's needed to make sure that we get you guys to the finish line, but without you not learning how to do it. We don't want to give you… like, we can give you an entire GitHub.
Hamza Farooq: with 20 projects, but that's not what we want to do. We want you
Hamza Farooq: To know how to build these things?
Hamza Farooq: And when we build… when you will build them, you will understand How they work.
Hamza Farooq: Right? That's the idea at the end of the day. We don't want you to be focused on, I'm gonna grab every single product that everyone has made, and we want you to be able to build 3, but do them correctly.
Hamza Farooq: Alright. Thank you, everyone. Take care, be well.
elie bassil: so much.
Hamza Farooq: We'll see you in the office hours. Take care.
Aishwarya Ashok: You folks. Yeah, see you folks.
Jonlin: Thank you.
Hamza Farooq: Bye, everyone.